the pregame
um before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in um let's get
started so a couple announcements before
we start the show guys as you already
know get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today if you want to know why we
have all this debauchery and craziness
in society all you got to do is look in
the 1900s when women got the right to
vote that was when everything went
downhill so if you want you want to see
that go away you think we're just too
wild with these decisions get yourself a
women shouldn't vote t-shirt
um okay a couple announcements guys
we're doing a meet up Sunday
um so it's at oh gosh I don't even know
if it's flat iron Brent square is it
Square I think it's Flatiron Square I'm
out in East London so um if you want to
come guys just all you got to do is show
up say hello it's going to be a lot of
fun old show guests are coming
um denalova's gonna be there so if you
guys miss you know super chatting and
how much you drove you nuts she's gonna
be there you can meet her um like the
video and also make sure you subscribe
to our new clips channels just Pearl
eclipse and pearl daily
um
King how many likes to open up the chat
tonight
1500 okay if we get to a thousand five
hundred likes we will open up the chat
to non-members if you want to be a part
of the chat otherwise make sure you sign
up for a five dollar tier
um and if you have any super chats over
how many dollars are we going to read
tonight 25. okay over 25 super chats we
will read so if you have something to
say a question for the panel make sure
you send a Super Chat and I think that
is it so okay welcome to the show
everybody
um why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age your relationship
status
um and why don't you tell me what you do
for a living go ahead hi I'm Gemma Lucy
I'm 35 years old
um I own a few businesses I also do any
fans and I'm currently seeing someone
hi I'm Jazz also known as G money
and I am a tattooist well practicing
tattoos and yeah I have a few businesses
as well
I'm Julia I'm 18 and I'm still in sixth
form
I'm JoJo I'm 30 and I'm a makeup artist
come on I'm 23 and I am a student at a
single song
I'm Angie montooth I'm 60 years old I
help people to become the best versions
of themselves
um I'm Solomon I'm a Content um and
media professional I'm 27 I'm married
and I've done this so many times I just
feel like everyone knows
um my name is China I'm the man named
voice and
um yeah yeah this week I celebrated the
year on on since my first time on just
purely thinking show so I'm back now oh
it's been a year it's been a year yeah
exactly yeah yeah yeah and obviously I
learned a lot of stuff being on Josh
Pali things show went viral I've been on
a lot of podcasts since then I've just
been monetizing quite a quite a short
time so I think in YouTube they say that
every time it's 18 months I think of
monetization
um so I did it in 10 months we could
have done a lot faster but so yeah so
yeah it's good to be back and yeah
thanks man whatever you what have you
learned in a year of shows oh my god
um
you need to have a thick skin for
YouTube because actually what happened
with me was shout out to my boy G-Shock
I never actually intended on doing
podcasts and it wasn't something I just
I've always spoken the way I've spoken
to my friends and what have you not he
said to me I think um it would be a good
idea to go on the show I came in the
show we had some viral Clips I think a
few of them got over 10 million views
and stuff and yeah and since then I got
asked to go on a lot of other podcasts
and then yeah I've been kind of doing
the rounds I kind of found myself I go
viral all the time almost every day
um and so it's kind of giving me the
confidence to do what I'm doing now and
the monetization and joining the YouTube
Partner is kind of that thing where
people always say oh not another podcast
or like or take a takeaway podcast for
men but when you get when you have an
audience they actually believe in you
and actually watch the content and
actually support you makes you know that
you're actually here for a reason so
you're coming Sunday right yeah I'm
gonna pull up something yeah he'll be
there Sunday guys I'm at the Meetup okay
so um today we're going to talk about
well modern women lose so guys I mean
I'm gonna I'm gonna introduce you to
some of my ideas don't know how familiar
you are with my content so we'll see you
know women you know we're a net loss on
the tax base meaning we spend more money
than we make right so men pay over a
hundred thousand dollars more in tax in
their lifetime yes so the majority of
people on benefits are women also and
you know now I would say we offer like
less to society than ever before we used
to offer like seven kids now the average
woman is given like 1.5 1.2 you know
they the guys used to marry us they used
to get like a nice young virgin now they
don't they they're like I'll pray for
that but it's not happening you know so
you know I had this thought Will Modern
women ever lose
is there ever a consequence for women
doing anything
um and what made me think of this was um
Lana Rhodes recently had a clip that
went viral if you want to pull it up
actually I think it might be a year or
two old but it made me think of this
because you know I I know she just got
pregnant by an NBA guy but we don't know
who like I know the baby daddy and I was
thinking like she essentially could put
a guy on child support for a lifetime
and boom she's done for a bad decision
now like now she's taken care of so
let's pull up this clip
such a fool in most of my decisions even
with all the success that you've had
your incredible mother now business
woman you're working with Playboy you
still look back on that and you still
feel ashamed
yeah I don't like the fact that people
can see me naked on the Internet or can
see those things happening to me I think
that it's gross
that is crazy that you can can build
this whole life and you still feel
ashamed I mean I'm I'm proud of myself
and what I've done and and I wouldn't
take anything back however it's not like
I love I like the idea that people can
view that of me I personally those
videos make me want to throw up
it was very much a
is there two is there a second one I was
gonna play both
my experiences are really humiliating
for me
and I wish that they never happened
sorry oh don't cry
and it just gets really extreme like you
were saying abusive um do I feel like
did you ever go through those
experiences where you honestly I feel
like I'm in denial sometimes and I can't
accept some of the things that I've done
some of my experiences are really
humiliating for me
okay so my question is you know she
talks about this the regret whatever but
she still works for Playboy and she's
worth 14 million dollars
so do modern women ever lose
I mean for 14 million dollars it's not
really losing is it
okay so you would say she doesn't lose
she wins it's different though because
she's obviously regretting what she's
done right so I can relate to her
because I do any fans and I hate what I
do but I'm stuck in a trap where I'm
trying to get out but I have a certain
lifestyle I have things to pay for it's
just difficult to just click your
fingers and how long have you done it
for I've done it for five years okay
I've built up businesses whilst I've
been doing it
um the reasons why I've done it is
probably trauma related and my
upbringing and things and I've ended up
in situations where I've been naive and
I've been taken advantage of not blaming
anyone but I know what I've been through
I know why I'm here and I'm trying to
get out of it so it's difficult to just
yes you can say she's humiliated and she
doesn't like it but maybe she can't
change it like that you know what I mean
well whoa she's worth 14 million dollars
can't she just like go go home
but when you make money if you've got
that kind of brain where you just want
more and more and more that doesn't stop
whether you've got 14 million 14 billion
so this is my thing I have a lot of only
fans models on the show yeah and I I
find that they kind of get into a
similar situation like you where they
don't know how to get out because
there's zero plan you know do you do you
find that to be true with the only fans
models that you know um yeah I like to
separate myself from a lot of the any
fans models because some of them say
stupid like my kids will cry in a
Ferrari and I think that's just dumb
when they get asked I don't know if you
saw that girl yeah yeah yeah
um like I have a daughter and there
isn't a day that goes by that you have a
daughter you do only fans
wow that's crazy
how would you do something is that crazy
shoes for
would you want your daughter to do only
fans no I wouldn't but that's why I'm
trying to stop doing it but I didn't
have a daughter when I started it sorry
I just this is just wow all right did
you want to pay my bills so no is that
okay can I answer the question
why should I pay your bills if you have
a daughter because you're cussing me I
haven't cost you also a question you're
looking at me and I said I haven't
looked at you know I just thought to be
honest with you you have a daughter you
just told me that you what did you do
apart from
there apart from this I do multiple
things I don't do all my friends I don't
sell my body online okay but what do you
do I'm not asking no I do multiple
things which is what multiple things I
can tell you about the things I do I'm a
landlord I'm a businesswoman I do have
sex and you do only
the problem is when you see when you're
not answering no see no no because what
you're missing well you're missing that
you're missing that you can easily Miss
nothing because because I'm about to get
onto something you're about to tell me
you do you're about to tell me I'm a
landlord you're about to tell me I'm a
businesswoman you're about to tell me
all of this and you're also about to
tell me you bus are open for 9.99 or
however how much money is online how
much is it so how much is it a month
sorry it's a lot of money
wait hold on a second hold on a second
hold on a second if you want to do that
because I generally ask you a genuine
question I don't want to do it while I'm
trying to come out okay so so let's work
on that let's let's work on that if you
want to come out when a man is asking
you a question and about to give you
some information possibly on how you can
take roots to come out you don't start
by questioning about what do you do
that's a very masculine thing so what
you want to do is you wait hold on a
second you want to battle me with what
you do but the basis of all the things
whoa you've got a daughter and you do
anything of course because because how
can you have a daughter and you'll be
selling your body online that's crazy I
agree with you which is why I want to
get out of it it's the way that you
spoke to her and said oh well you have a
daughter like thank you like so she has
a daughter okay so what she's trying to
put money on food for her she can't work
in Tesco's that's nine pound an hour
wait hold on a second
about all the other people and now are
putting in the school okay
everyone in Tesco because they won't
because they know what I'm talking about
how much time
24 water you look who work in Tesco's
you put your kids in schools in
nurseries and Oscars
I'm just curious do you seriously think
it's better for a kid to have a mom on
only fans than a mom working at Tesco
but I'm not saying it's better but I'm
saying both things have their good and
bad points because at least I raise my
daughter
I'd like to hear the man's point the
problem is we can't do this if you're
going to continue because you're getting
triggered the reason you're getting
triggered because you know what I'm
going to say because you've heard it
before the what you're gonna see
what are you swearing for there's no
need that's very rude you're swearing to
a man you've never met before I haven't
swore at you that's very disrespectful
I've not once I've been disrespecting
you yes you have you said you've got a
daughter and you do any fans I think
most men will be would say that you've
got the daughter oh my man don't say
that so what no but right but you do I'm
just confused because you just said that
you have a daughter and you do only fans
and when he said it back to you you got
mad
I know I have a daughter I know I do
anything I'm trying to get out of it
right so let me speak then
hold on
biggest women the first a question we
have to answer is is it true well as
what the guy is saying is true
but it's like but but it's like is it
true and he's just repeating back what
you said
do you want to stop don't let me speak
them I started only fans yeah I was I
was led down a path Where I Was Naive
I've ended up on only fans and my plan
is to get off it and try and get rid of
as much as possible I'm gonna have to
deal with that as a man but I tell you
what I wouldn't swap any job for
spending 20. you said you're yeah how
are you naive if you were 29. no but I
was naive to end up in other things
has nothing to do with age though why
has nothing to do with age I agree
I think if you're like almost halfway
through life you have a little more
wisdom no I don't think so because you
need to be accountable see this thing
men we cannot go through our life not
being accountable you guys can how can
you be 29 you're about to tell me 29 I
was groomed into only fans
no but this is this is where you're
trying to take it when you're talking
about what do you do what's your job
what do you mean I own Iceland shoe and
I do podcasts I slush you can I can I
make a point you've never heard of it so
what does that mean so hold on a second
what do you do you said you sing you're
a student and I sing and you sing
and then you said to him what do you do
because you haven't heard of it so then
I said to you what do you do you sing
it's coming how dare you but you're
getting triggered I'm not getting
triggered I'm not no I'm not getting
triggered I'm not getting triggered I'm
not you asked me a question what do you
do you didn't know what I did so that's
your ignorance you've never watched this
show you've never seen who I am so
you're asking me what that's your
ignorance I ask you what you do you
don't do much so what are you talking
about yeah so yeah why are you being
aggressive I'm not aggressive the
problem is
the problem is
I'll give you an example you said one
thing he said the same thing back to you
you don't like how we said it because
it's disrespectful it's a disrespect
it's disrespectful exactly what have you
got yeah you said but see it's so funny
because this is what they do we're not
talking about me right now we're talking
about you
and it's so interesting because you know
what they do it's like you you say one
thing and then he says it back to you
and then you get mad no it's not that
this because the way he said it I think
I agree
because he had a point let me finish he
had a point right and the thing is as
women there is certain things that we
don't like to do let's take
responsibility
consequences of our actions now I don't
agree with if anybody sort of looking at
somebody as though what they do is wrong
bad or anything but there are
consequences to our actions and whether
we like it or not I think the man's
reaction to what you did was yes he did
react but it was because you have a
four-year-old daughter and a man no
daughter not his son no no no no let me
let me explain can a man not feel some
sort of responsibility or sort of think
about how that child might feel
it doesn't matter we are all parents of
all children if I see a child on the
street I care about how my child feels
way more than anything if you did you
want to be doing only fans if I see a
child on the streets
listen if I see a child on the street by
themselves I care about that child I do
like you know what's crazy to me you
guys you guys
like you're Reinventing the will you're
not doing anything you're not creating
businesses you're not what are you doing
can you stop interrupting me you're
being very rude
guys you keep interrupting me do you
know what it is this is masculinity and
the problem is women always try women
all try to tone police from the moment
I've started I've not been rude I'm
having to now raise my voice
from the beginning
let me show you what women do
this is live on Earth this is live on
air I've been called aggressive I'm
being called aggressive super chat later
on I've been called aggressive I've not
been disrespectful I've not shout out to
them I haven't I haven't used any
devocatory any comments on that all I
simply says wow you have a four-year-old
daughter and you do only fans I was
gonna go on for that and explain because
I've done this scenario before but the
problem is you get triggered because
this is not the first time you've heard
this it's not the first time oh okay
okay wait can I reply no because because
I'm trying to say something you keep
stopping it I can't get to it and the
problem is this is a trauma response I
get it I understand I get it I get it I
understand it's a trauma response trying
to come to me and telling me Oh what do
you do oh what you're trying to do
that's a very masculine thing what
you're trying to say is oh oh let me
check what you do but it doesn't matter
what I do I could clean the streets
that's still better than doing only fans
because
wait wait wait wait
there's one thing you guys really think
that doing only fans is is not a worse
job than others you asked about them
woman all right no I'm asking you oh my
fair okay we really think that like
sweeping the street being a street
sweeper is people don't respect those
people either
hold on a second these are the men that
built these are the men that built the
modern world you women don't respect
that you women don't respect the people
that um
you just said you just said you don't
respect them of course
I said that people do who doesn't which
people I respect them
do you understand do you think that
someone who does only fans can't raise a
child
I didn't say that no but as long as he's
taking care of her childhood
I went to the question was do you think
that somebody who does only fans can't
still raise their child with good morals
respect and properly no no I think okay
but then if I was in between history
then someone else is raising my channel
I mean that's how you're like you're
supposed to get married before the kid
so then you have a husband yeah but that
didn't happen for me because it's choice
right that's a choice
and and I don't have a kid I'm not an
only fan yeah
all right all right guys
I'm going to need to
calm this thing down and we we read the
rules please let's I know it's hard when
we're all trying to get our points
across but if someone is speaking let's
all try to give them a chance to speak
there are too many of the women I think
have emotional responses and we become
defensive because of our history because
of what we've been through in the past
and we get triggered and rather than
allow someone to speak and hear the full
length of what they have to say where
maybe we can learn something and take
something on board
it might hurt because we're triggered
but that doesn't mean what he had to say
might not have made some sense I say
might not because I didn't hear it let
me just trigger let me just finish
darling please okay one just one thing
because I'm not against you
don't don't okay but I'm not against him
either as women we need to get to
understand masculine energy it's not a
negative because it's louder or stronger
or more assertive that's what masculine
is right we are the opposite we are
feminine and sometimes we have to learn
how to allow that so that maybe we can
like please I've had plenty of
conversations with people I've been on
Plenty of podcasts where the opposite
person doesn't agree with only fans and
we've spoke very maturely like adults
respectfully and I agree with a lot of
points that someone who doesn't agree
with only fans I agree with a lot of
things they say but it's the way someone
addresses it and I'm sorry but both of
you have been rude and and the way you
address it is rude I know that's the
whole point of the podcast but I could
have a conversation for hours about with
somebody who doesn't agree with only
fans and it will not get heated and I
will agree with things that they say and
they'll agree with what did we what did
we say that was so rude it's the way you
see no no I'm asking what what
specifically did we say I've already
said no no you do we want to go back
over it no please because I still don't
know
you've got a four-year-old then you do
anything yeah wow that was a question
that's not real that's a question what
can I ask you though it's that reaction
abnormal pardon yes so so most people
say when you when people say oh do you
actually have a door and do any fans
like do you not think there's something
better you could do and I'll be like
yeah to be honest
but the thing is I'm like she said I'm
not for him and I'm not for you like I'm
not against the both of you but I think
that we should be able to own the
consequences of our choices right like I
don't know his whole energy is
aggressive I don't like it no and and
some people would see you a certain way
yes I'm triggered more by his aggression
than what he said I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I can't I can't I can't do this I can't
do this I can't as a black man have have
a white woman calling me aggressive
online I'm not doing this I'm not doing
this let me tell you why because if you
call me aggressive off camera
a problem happens to me but call me
aggressive on camera when I've not shown
anything aggression other masculinity
the problem is you guys try to tone
police this is the thing what you're
saying you don't understand masculinity
because in today's society they try to
hold a black man though
right you have just called me I've never
said anything about to hold on hold on a
second let me speak you're doing it
again I'm telling you I'm telling you my
I'm telling you my feeling I'm telling
you how I'm how I'm perceiving you how
I'm receiving it down so you can't you
can't do it hold on hold on wait hold on
hold on you won't let me speak what I
said about black girls told me you've
spoken on your podcast about black girls
wearing fake hair baby mama don't don't
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute okay wait what have I said what
have I said we're gonna do it now so I'm
gonna let you say what you think I've
said then I'm going to speak you said
stuff about black girls what am I saying
fake weave what I said whatever
what did I say you said that why do
black girls wear fake hair receipts
[Music]
put it out get your phone out don't you
ever accuse me of this in black women
pull up receipts no because you did no
these are my sisters
yeah yeah cool
masculinity
no no no no no no no
set the record straight what did you say
then what did you say hold on I'm Jazz
if a woman says to me
what did you say it's not history it's
not for me to say what I've said it's
for the person to say that accusing me
and to show me what they said
what I'm saying find your phone
I've never said nothing about black
women
that guys to be fair it's like a third
of kids nowadays are born into single
mother homes
because of the woman yeah because
women make stupid decisions
who you you pick who your baby daddy is
so if you got a shitty Baby Daddy it's
your own they might not have been hit
before though
let me let me get this straight um did
your parents like him did your friends
like him really they all said flying
colors he's so amazing and then he just
switched like that might be okay
that's never the case
there's not a single case like that
where a guy's gonna fool all of the men
in her life that's gonna fool the Father
the Brothers cousins
well then it's your mom's fault to be
honest yeah it's your mom's fault yes
show me where I'm dissing black women
listen
you know
okay okay so which part of that is a man
dissing black woman's hair in actual
fact I'm talking about I grew up in a
household we've I got three sisters of
my mother right I know what it is so we
grew up in in those days they would
relax your hair so my sister had a hairy
like she destroy the hair all of my
three sister had the head destroyed as
they grew up older then they started to
um they had their natural hair right and
I've discussed and I witnessed what
happened till now I've got nieces I've
got nieces and nephews all of their
heads are natural because of what we
learned in those days we used to use
something called
um Dark and Lovely and it would destroy
your hair and it absolutely destroyed it
and it comes from that thing where
straight hair is better right so I'm
speaking from this point the thing is
Right a lot of black women will say you
know what it's a protective style so
I'll say if it's a protective style then
wear something more um natural towards
your hair right they'll say oh you know
what I can't wear it to work so I'll say
you know what if you go to a place and
they don't allow you to work in there
you know what maybe you shouldn't be
working in actual fact maybe we should
build our own everyone I speak about is
empowering the young black girl what do
we say to a young black girl when we say
to her in order for you to go out and be
successful you need to put on European
um um Chinese Peruvian Brazilians wait
hold on can what do we say when every
single day you get up and you have to
put off something over your head if it
was strictly protective style you could
use braids you could use something else
so what you're trying to do is you're
trying to take a man that is talking
about something serious within the black
community who has nieces who God willing
one day or have daughters and I'm going
to spend time like I spend with my
nieces everyone see me on social media
all the time I spend my nieces doing her
hair I've made it into my niece is
actually um a model and she's actually
doing really well she's done commercials
already and this all comes from all the
love so you take something a black man
that cares about his community who loves
his black women and he tried to make
into evil thing I'm disgusted by you all
right are you done are you know because
no because what you try to do is you
tried to pull out receipts and I
explained to you I never once this
thought I'm talking about deeper rooted
issues no no you actually say you're
saying that it's because we're saying
that their hair is not that no actually
certain Works places when you do wear
your black hair you get questions you
get people touching your hair
the crown Act was created in America
because of discrimination so you know we
do system we build our own thank you no
no no no no that's not as easy it's not
it's not easy
okay so what we're doing now so what
we're doing now now what we're doing now
we're doing that thing where I told you
we built that only said it's I know it's
not easy it's never easy that's the
problem that's the problem it's not
supposed to be easy and because it's
hard you don't want to do it but you're
not saying you like black girls natural
hair you like it when it's when it's
curly when it looks like mixed race
this is a fallacy this is not true I'm a
black woman you're speaking to me you
don't know hello I'm a black woman and
what you just said there is not true
okay it's not true I tell you why
absolutely
let me tell you why it's not true
let me let her finish again
let me tell you I'm 60 years old okay
and when I was 18 we were wearing weaves
and wigs and we're still wearing them in
fact we're wearing more
and I know that I would say most let me
not say all most black men prefer your
own hair they don't like the smell of
the weave nope they don't like the way
the The Weave takes away your hairline
nope they don't like the way the weave
balls off your head nope but deeper than
that because I'm a black woman and I
used to wear weave okay
and I understand what a society that is
endemically racist
can do to you so you feel so bad about
your own hair your natural hair and that
point you made about going to work
if you want to have your hair in locks
or you want to have your hair in braids
or you want to plait your hair
it's like it's not good we used to use
it uh what you call those things uh
uh one of those iron Combs thank you
burn your hair burn your scalp so that
your hair wouldn't be so frizzy and
whatever right so what I said no I'd
like to finish okay so the point that he
made sometimes as women we prefer to
listen to our friends and say oh your
hair looks nice the wig looks nice do we
and then the man's telling you I don't
like it so what you're saying is what
you're doing everything for a man so as
long as I never said that but you're
saying mum doesn't like me no no no
don't misinterpret it literally two
minutes ago a man doesn't like when it
looks like that
she said that that men actually like you
know black women's hair being curly that
was what she was with her perception of
men she knows of course she just don't
she's just different Jim she just told
her man she doesn't know that I don't
like black women with natural hair like
she literally and the whole fact
on black women's hair yeah no first of
all you said that this black woman then
you sort of like curly hair you don't
know what type of hair I like never said
he was saying that he likes the natural
hold on a second hold on a second no no
no that's not even what I said I said
that this comes this this actually comes
from slavery time this comes from the
the the the the the field the field
the house the house David come
from
no because I'm trying to make you
understand something where this comes
from because you have to understand what
we're dealing with here you're battling
a man a black man that is talking about
who who has sisters who has nieces that
have gone through who have destroyed
their hair who now are natural who has
gone through that who now has nieces
that his mother and grandmother would
never ever do to their head because they
realize the damage is done to them I'm
speaking from that and when I speak you
speak like I'm distant women you speak
like I'm hurting women why even speak on
black women's hair hold on a second why
do you care what because I'm a black
because I'm a black man hold on a second
you wanna separate for me this is like
saying when black women okay so the
crime that's happening with the black
kids they're stabbing on what happened
what have you not you can speak on that
would you ever hear a man say oh why are
you speaking on on the black you if
you're in a black youth of course we are
not separate this thing where you try to
say why are you so what if I have a
daughter I can't speak on black woman's
hair you just said you want to know what
texture uh hey your daughter's gonna
have why does that it's not I want to
know is why are you here's the thing
right if you're bored if you're bored
you're bored I love you because you're
bored I don't actually care about hair
I'll prefer women bored than having some
other woman's hair that's the thing and
if I want if you want to wear a European
and it's a thing it's not even European
not Asian Asian even are you Asian why
are you an Asian
it's not that I care you keep this and
this is
not right now see the finger no you keep
doing this right but you said that this
black woman said I didn't I was
speakingly talking about well that's how
it was perceived and other people in in
this podcast has said that it was said
in a negative light and that is how I
took it I don't think if you don't think
that you was being negative about it and
another thing to say you're not saying
Oh I like that but why is that why is
that always how you guys feel but sort
of what he said because like because you
guys don't take that crazy words
it such as you guys it's just like women
it's like we don't take the actual
information like what he said it's
always how it made us feel about the
information okay
this black woman and I told you to to
bring out those seats when you didn't
okay I wanna I wanna go I want to go
back to the topic sorry I don't even
know what a teaching Union is I don't
understand it like honestly because
you're telling me debunk something when
you pull that dead receipts I can't oh
mate sorry okay okay
um okay
um what did you want to say about the
only fans in the kid you had a point you
had a point I need you to shh did you
did you have anything else I know you're
at a point so I was like look my thing
is this right right
you don't know what it is especially for
for you're doing a daughter it was a boy
it would be just as bad but you're
raising a daughter and you're doing only
fans at the end of the day it's just a
thing where it is
it's it's basically online prostitution
and you might you might want to a
prostitution I'm not selling my
yeah what are you saying that is
it's the oldest oldest industry what do
you what are you doing only fans
subscribe
so what kind of stuff what do you sell
you're saying subscribe to find out
at the end of the day yeah without all
the AG without other arguing without all
the like getting on top of each other
I'm I will sit here and say I'm not
proud of what I do and I want to change
it whether you guys think I should have
changed it sooner should have never done
it all of that cool I haven't got time
to sit here and tell you my whole life
story and plus other people have got
things to say but I want to get out of
it and I'm trying and that's it can I be
honest with you if you said that to me
this conversation would have gone so
much differently I swear to God it's the
way you were dressed no but you could
have been through no but you keep saying
and this is the thing you keep saying
it's the way I know you've got a
daughter
and this is the thing and this is the
thing yeah okay I'll give you that I'm
just curious like what do you think is
like supposed to be the
reactions
and I'm just saying like what do you
expect what do you expect someone can
still be polite
okay it's like I know someone that
robbed a bank who cares
you know like when you're unemployed
yeah and someone keeps bugging you every
single day instead of you've got a job
yet have you got a job yet have you got
a job yet and then on a certain day
knowing that you've been trying to get a
job for how long and then they come back
again have you got a job yet it starts
to get on your nerves because it's like
I'm like you don't know what's going on
okay
but China the person's trying okay my
point is they're trying to they actually
try it's just like her story she wants
to come out the industry okay but so
obviously it's going to trigger her when
somebody comes straight at her like that
oh you got it she's probably thinking
that you don't know that she's probably
thinking okay
every minute of every day I think that
thing that's the trigger okay but yeah
but like my question is McDonald's is
hiring then stop don't work at
McDonald's
when I look after my daughter when I'm
in McDonald's who because I can't afford
it someone has their reasons sorry don't
you have a boyfriend yes I do business
so I'm saying like work something out
I've been with my boyfriend for like a
month
about my boyfriend have I got a
boyfriend no by myself yeah yeah
terrible life yeah so it's just so awful
go ahead I I wanted to ask you um I hear
that you want to stop and I hear that
you know you talked about how trauma
actually LED you there so my thing is
what are the practical steps that you
are taking right now to stop or is is it
just like a resolution in your mind no
I'm building businesses I've got a
proper property portfolio I've got five
properties under my belt I'm about to
have another five next year I want to
make my property portfolio so big that
in two years time I won't have to do it
anymore I can pay someone to get as much
of it off the internet as possible yes I
know it probably won't all come off the
internet but I'm just gonna try my best
you have five businesses though five
businesses
it's not enough financially no but do
you know what's so interesting how you
guys said big up to her businesses but
we're trying to shame his
my language
and this is the thing guys this is the
thing guys right this is this is more
than women this is how they feel they
can call them they can call a man a
that they've never met before
because they feel that safe they feel
that safe you can just call what you're
gonna do and guys you see that there
what are you going to do no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no what are
you gonna do I'm giving an example not
would you ever tell me right now what
you're gonna do to me
why would you not do that I just think
is if it's not necessary but what could
happen if you tell me that
honestly punched
uh if there is a king king
what would happen if you just if I just
said that to you what would you do bro
it's on it's on hold on a second hold on
a second security what would happen if I
just said that to you
so this is more than women
guys that are like they will get
up and slap you because I'm raised by it
because I'm raised by my mother and my
father I have three sisters and nieces I
would never do such a thing but let me
tell you something you see what that um
the last we had that woman with the
brick in the face apparent brick in the
face not breaking Aphasia and one of the
things was everyone's talking about
women going up in man's faces yeah you
don't know me from anywhere you have
just disrespected me let me tell you
something just like women know yeah you
say that to the wrong guy come up when I
box you now
you say you're doing all these things
all you've come and done has been so
aggressive towards me see you just call
man a like seriously it's giving
sassy see the thing is you know and
because
men understand aggression they're
different sorry there's different forms
of aggression it's giving sassy it's
giving bitsy all of these things
because
that's aggression
this is the thing we've lived such easy
lives as women that she doesn't even
understand there's consequences for her
actions because it goes back to it we
get away with everything you can talk
however you want and nothing will happen
because men built this society that lets
us do damn near whatever we want and
then we disrespect man as a thank you
what's alive
that's a big lie okay okay who built the
building it doesn't matter
there's zero consequences for women
very little little to none
okay okay okay okay
100.
right now
thank you
um do they do men and women get equal
sentencings for the same crimes no no
it's not even the ever situation no no
no no no no no no no they never have
they haven't for a hundred plus so
you're telling me every morning they get
the same sentence men get four times the
amount of sentencing for the same crime
as a woman
you can you can you can yes you can you
cannot you cannot believe it right but
it's true men absolutely get higher
prison sentencing for the same crime and
you see all these women killing their
babies killing their children right
throwing them in dumpsters how many have
we seen get off
oh no it's pretty common it's pretty
common there's multiple cases in the U I
can't remember the name off the top of
my head but it's well baby it's
happening what do you mean they get off
like they don't they don't they don't go
to jail a lot of the time and this is
this is this is even America UK
from the UK okay okay I'll give you Lucy
leppy she was a nurse for seven years
before they suggested her you think if a
guy was doing the same thing he wouldn't
have been questioned yeah yeah
it doesn't but she was a woman right I
didn't say it was just because she was a
woman I I didn't say it was that like
that was the only Factor as well the
sentence in it's not just
a race as well my whole my whole point
is women do not have the same
consequences that men do never do this
is just this is just the YouTube
you keep you keep moving it right we're
talking about gender women women do not
have the same consequences how many
women's shelters are there
really like come on you're letting your
ignorance shoot you like if you want to
come against the point at least be sure
what you're saying literally everywhere
you go White Chapel alone you can go
downstairs right there I can you we will
literally count way more than 30
homeless men right there on the streets
right there
so
why are there only women's abuse
shelters why aren't there men's abuse
shelters so I interviewed Aaron pizzi
she started the first abuse shelter in
the UK so it all started with her and
she'll tell you that women are just as
violent as the men so where are the
men's shelters
oh crickets nowhere okay because wimp
because again women do not have the same
consequences that men do there's all of
these government programs for women we
have quotas you know we we get special
jobs I've even talked to recruiters
about this for high paying jobs they
discriminate against men and they they
pick women over men those women are
marginalized moving on women are not
marginalized but do women women okay
okay okay okay
so I have a question I have a question
how are women marginalized women are
marginalized because women are abused at
higher rates no they're not that's not
true
it's not it's roughly the same no it's
it's roughly okay okay if I go out at
night at 2 A.M in the morning my mom my
mom is gonna tell me don't go outside
you know you're a woman a man is not
going to be why are you why are you
entitled safety I need to address that
point too this is this is this is this
is this is everyone should be no no no
hello guys I need to address and this is
this is a misconception you women have
now you think that women are told oh
don't go out because this is dangerous
at night men don't get told that because
men know that in Italy okay yeah but I'm
not going to go hold up yes a lot of men
are strong but there are also other men
that are stronger that's the point so
exactly just because I'm stronger than
50 men stronger than me that are ready
to kill me outside exactly
my point is my point is she made a point
she made a point that manner 88 of all
homicides yeah she made it points that
her mom tells her oh be careful don't go
out at night this is something every man
has been told from When We're Young you
don't go out at night unless you're
ready to face whatever consequences
you're going to meet outside listen the
streets are more dangerous okay for a
man to go out at night
I have a question I have a question we
have as women a perceived Danger
I agree with you because if we go out at
night something can definitely happen to
us
and therefore if we were to take an Uber
rather than walk the streets
okay two o'clock in the morning three
o'clock in the morning will hopefully be
safer
but young men going out right now on the
streets
do you know how panicking it is for them
in terms of whether they'll meet up with
some other guys or gang stabbings
etc etc that's again about choice if
you're anything right so let's say
okay okay I have a question I have a
question I have a question uh who is
more likely to get help if they're
attacked a man or a woman a woman a
woman exactly
you know so yes exactly if I'm walking
down the street like if I'm walking down
this White Chapel yes you might look at
me um this big tall guy I'm strong and
all that even when I'm walking past 14
year old kids my Spider Sense is
literally tingling because at any second
Anything Could Happen
you women don't even realize that you
weren't just walking down the street
yeah you might have the passive danger
of yeah a man might cut call me or a man
might try to touch me or do but you
don't have the things I'm trying to
touch you though like I'm sorry every
single man in this room if they wanted
to could could put force on all of us
exactly nothing about it exactly yeah I
agree I agree with that right but but
every single man in this room could also
potentially come to your Aid we don't
have that really come men men really
come okay
so you call the police who's coming
most likely okay well so who's coming
who's coming who's coming who's coming
no no no no it's not your show no no I'm
just trying to answer the question who's
coming okay okay for that wait wait for
the but see this is what I mean you're
entitled women live such good lives you
feel entitled to safety that has never
happened
but that going alone at night is a
luxury why do you do it oh you said that
I don't because I do not feel safe but
man but men don't feel safe at night but
what they don't feel safe because of
other men yeah but women don't say
because of them so who's the problem
here one thing you need to realize
woman won't attack me she might but this
is statistically you will be a man oh
I've only been attacked by women I'll
tell you that
once again
so if we go if we're going to go back to
this if we go to war who's going
man okay okay okay
so so again how how are we oppressed
when the men are the ones that have to
risk their lives to protect us
there is women no they're Selective
Service they're not on the front line
because they wouldn't put them on the
phone line imagine there was out in
Afghanistan and we put all our women on
there right but who you can't wait to
see the comments
will you go to Afghanistan tonight
let's just go let's just go in this room
for my country I would some all right
some crazy person walks in with a gun
just into this room and all the men run
away how would you feel if all the men
actually running are you gonna run away
I wouldn't expect you to do anything I
would protect myself
I have a question this is my security
guard you're gonna protect yourself
against no you said over God no no you
said okay well if someone physically
bigger than me physically attacked me
the difference
no no don't get rid of the gun what you
think and so you really think that if he
works in here with a gun and you have a
gun you're gonna get the best oh I'm
running so what the hell are you talking
about there your point was how would you
feel if I if older men would start
running yeah everyone's protecting
himself literally everyone
so generally you don't expect men to
protect women yeah because they they
don't like cats
do you expect your husband to protect
you when you eventually get married if
you want to yes because I chose that
husband for a reason because I know that
specific man will protect me that's why
why do you think that he should protect
you in different situations
why don't women
want to do that
I have a question I have a question do
you think do you think do you think
protection is a luxury or do you think
you're entitled to it
okay okay okay so what have what have
you done to deserve protect
when has it ever been a fundamental
human right that you did not have to
protect
what you mean you have so because even
in America right people will come they
come that's why we have had Wars right
we've fought a whole War over this so
it's not just something given you have
to earn it and protect it yes
how how did how did we earn it
historically we went to war in the
winners one in the losers have you been
in a fight before
oh hell no I I have security okay so
this is my point so I've been in I've
got eight brothers yeah right when I'm
out with my little one my little brother
for example yeah and if somebody I saw
somebody approaching him
I will literally go mad on whoever it is
I will protect my brother
that comes from what's inside that's not
nothing nothing to earned irrespect you
ain't got to force me to do that yeah
and I don't care if it's my older
brother or my little brother or his
brother
too because you guys are family right no
no no no if I know the person as well
that's that's the point right you know
them you're not just gonna get them up
no no it doesn't matter have you been in
it no you haven't I'll speak from my
perspective I've seen when something has
gone down and I know when something's
wrong I can something inside here if you
ain't got inside you that's something
but my point is you're still you're
still you're still a chick you can't you
can only do so much yeah exactly
she said you could only do so much
he said you you kind of made this
wonderful statement of how you you are a
woman and you protect a man no no I'm
talking I didn't say as a woman I'm
talking about
so my point is
yes as lovely as that sounds
yes in an idealistic world we might look
at you as a hero but I'm not I'm not
even trying to be rude that is literally
the worst thing you can do as a woman
try to go out in the world try to
protect men because I'm Batman now I'm
Batman sorry I'm growing up are you
going to listen I said if something
happened then and my point is my
instinct is
guys guys let him talk for a minute I'm
trying not interrupting him Jesus when
you are speaking about your younger
brother I couldn't even understand that
yeah he's your younger brother yes you
should protect him because he's more
vulnerable than you are but when you
start bringing in the part of even if
it's my older brother I think that is
coming from a very masculine standpoint
and you might think it's not but that's
the reality you might think it's not
gender-based for you to protect others
but it actually is it's a masculine
treaty the reason why you feel the
reason why you feel like you should do
that is exactly because of what you say
because you ground you grew up around so
many boys so you've picked up a lot of
masculine traits without even realizing
it then tell my mom that as well
as a woman you shouldn't go out in the
world when you see men getting at it
physically and try to insert yourself
I'm telling you because you're you're
more than likely going to be the one to
come out with worse injuries I'm glad
it's just common sense it is common
sense and that's why women feel like if
there was a situation where there's a
man involved they feel like oh my god
well what could I do
to this person versus this person here
who's a man but my point but my point is
my point is that men built the entire
world and they give us protection it is
a gift and we are super rude and
disrespectful to them
okay you were very rude to him like 10
minutes ago
what happened in the lift when we came
up to live together because you said
about I won't protect people what did I
do no I'm thinking about when she's hold
on wait hold on no no no no no forget
that because if I what did I do in the
living thing
I've got a little phobia and he very
kindly got in the lift with me and just
said breathe Reef
hold on I said I met you for the first
time I told you to come if you said to
me wait hold on a second you said to him
you've got a phobia I told you we're
going up to the 21st I said thank you
this is not about this is what I
appreciate it
on the story please I've met you for the
first time yes we've come through the
door use with your partner you told him
you don't need to follow you upstairs
yes you have a partner kiss you up and
you came inside right you said you're
gonna go up to the 21st floor yeah I
told you that's a lot of steps we
couldn't it's got a sweat card you can't
come in I said come in the lift she said
she's got a phobia we counted up the
lips I told her to look on her floors
look at her toes to breathe with me I
told him not to look at anything and we
did this we got to the 21st floor then
she gave me a hug now I just met her now
a second ago you said that men won't do
something now you're talking about
common decent it's not common decency
thank you the issue is it's it's so
entitled this is so entitled men built
this entire world for women
wait Jesus Christ it's like you feel
entitled to talk on the podcast
wait see that's what I mean okay so it's
like men built this entire world though
the majority of the police force or the
majority of the military they're the
ones that are going to step in if
somebody hurts you outside
Jesus wait and so it's a little It's
like because you don't know how to
listen for five wait wait see there what
like what are you five
by God it's like met they build this
world for us they build the buildings
they do all of the hard jobs 45 half of
men do a job that runs the
infrastructure of society 45 amends that
means they're they're building the
buildings they're doing the plumbing
they're doing the electricity they're on
a power grid men build society and give
us these useless jobs so we think we're
more important than we are because we're
on only fans are singing and we think
that's equally important
sections
the thing is we can't even you can't
even listen
you can't even listen without hearing
the information without getting mad
because wait wait wait no no question
because I have looked at I have looked
at the data I've looked at the jobs that
women are mostly and it's mostly nursing
Administration teaching these are not as
useful objectively Society no it's not
Society
wait see see you guys see do you see you
can't listen two minutes just wait Jesus
Christ uh it's like teaching is not as
important because they used to
homeschool and and our IQ test you know
it's funny and it's so funny I'll tell
you in the 80s women infiltrated
education meaning before it was mostly
men now it's mostly women there's a
teacher and a teacher's aide two women
cannot teach as well as one man used to
yup yup meaning men can do our jobs
better than us in general so back in the
80s right yes so obviously time has
changed so now a man
I think we should go back I mean we
can't do it right
wait wait wait wait wait wait and you
know what's funny it's actually you're
wrong you're not even correct there have
always been influential women in history
there's always been women leading
political movements in the 1800s 1900s
1600s there's a there's Cleopatra Joan
of Arc no women have not historically
fought in Worlds of course historically
in general there's been exceptions but
not the rule occasionally occasionally
um there have been women queens and you
know what they're more likely to do wage
war because typically they don't have a
consequence so you shouldn't be running
through the podcast then exactly a
mansion
you can't do that properly then
according to your logic you should be
running a podcast you know and and
here's here's the funny thing here's the
funny thing you know they're smart men
that do what I do too there there are
there I would suggestions
you know what's so funny you know it's
so funny it's like you guys try to go
personal because you don't like the
information
that's not what I said though you guys
don't listen to what I said there have
always been women and political in
political movements okay but we do about
ratios though based on your point right
women can't basically do anything that
men can do
it
no no that's not what I said there's
except there's always been high IQ
influential women in history but they're
not the rule they're not they're not the
rule it's the exception it's not the
rule what do you mean they're they're
because okay for every 10 smart men
there are there's one smart woman okay
so occasionally
you you asked what it means to be an
exception and what it means
so and I'll tell you why when they
switch the the IQ test and they switched
the school system to make it more
feminine how um so I'll give you an
example the writing section A lot of
times that's ideological meaning that if
you don't put the right ideological
talking points that are more leftist you
you get points taken off
yes yes I am and I'll tell you and I'll
tell you I'll tell you why see I'll tell
you why I'm actually quite smart but I
do think it's pretty idiotic and I do
think it's pretty oddic when you can do
anything and you go on only fans yeah
it's like
you could do anything
and I'm not even talking about you
personally we have more only fans models
than teachers now so so yesterday
a lot of modern women actually club for
only fans
she said something initially she said
who respects people who work at test
school but people respect quote-unquote
according to possibly what she was
actually saying
if you are actually you know and only
fans more than you're making a lot of
money then you are respectable
hold on hold on everyone to Tesco now
and see that you're using the Tesco as
an example I'm just going to stick with
that you went to Tesco now and asked any
of the women with singular women would
you rather do only fans or what do you
think about women who do anything do you
think any one of them is going to be
like yeah yeah they do because they
could be doing it too
where are you are you on Instagram
they had an entire parade that was
dedicated to shaming are you
kidding me yes
you can't you can't say they won't
parade it when they literally did yeah
well you know what I think I think we're
missing something I don't think we
should make this about I'm sorry I don't
remember your name Emma right because
the first thing she said is she wants to
get out of it but women are being
sexualized and social media is
programming our young women as far as
I'm concerned and that programming they
think that if they put their bottom out
and their breasts out they're gonna get
more what is it likes and Views and they
do right you can have
um somebody who maybe is dressed a
certain way
and it's not going to get the sort of
traction as someone who might put their
nipples out thanks that's just facts so
then therefore young people's minds
think okay well I'll show a little bit
of this and I'll go like that and it
works so we have to remember that
Society also there are influences and
unless people are brought up by certain
types of parenting that doesn't always
work because I mean you can do your own
thing but when you look at even Netflix
or streaming excuse me maybe I shouldn't
talk about any particular
um streamer but do you understand my
point so and going back to your point in
terms of Education
how are our children being educated can
I just say something you're saying that
women are being sexualized more than
that's not true because if you look at
stars like Marilyn Monroe Cleopatra all
these your 60s so you should know
Marilyn Monroe I didn't say that she
wasn't I'm just saying that women are
being sexualized
a bit of social media it is
100 100 years ago 85 of women were
virgins or at least that's what they
claimed but let's let's say let's say
let's say they're lying and we double it
that's still too yeah
this is 2023 babe
because you said that this isn't like
this time it's this isn't new and I'm
saying yes it is it's actually super new
at this time in history to be this
promiscuous like there's always been
there's always been a class of
concubines yes there's always been a
class of concubines but it's been really
small in in compared to the rest of the
population but then could it be argued
that men are the issue them because
who's sexualizing yeah so I actually
have thought about this a little bit and
I kind of I kind of go but I I used to
think that too but then I thought about
it I think women take off their clothes
first before the men ask for sex and the
reason I think this is because I go to
Vegas and there's literally women
walking around with stickers on their
boobs sorry I need to I need to draw
attention to something so it's funny how
like you keep saying the language we use
is very important language is a tool of
communication and if we don't use it
properly we tend to pass on the wrong
information now you said women have been
sexualized now maybe that was true in
the past but today I actually think
women sexualize themselves I don't
disagree that's one yeah
my point was was the programming yeah no
but but that's what I want to come to
now so the point is you said there's a
programming that's now making women
sexualize themselves more so and then on
this Direction
one second please one second please yes
I agree but on the power you say that
now and then on the parallel some women
will also come out and and try to argue
Pearl's point that women are just as
smart as men okay if that were true
and if we were to put in accountability
into this equation
now let's put an analogy there is a push
to make young men go into the street and
sell drugs now do we come out and say oh
yeah but the society is trying to make
men go out and sell drugs so now we
should feel sorry for the men that go
out and do it but we do do we know
this is my point I actually believe we
don't and I believe men don't so and if
women are doing that you are
contributing to the problems
but you see that's the thing that's this
is this is what you call virtue
signaling when you say women are more
empathetic how is it more empathetic how
is that virtual signaling can you let me
make my points how is it more empathetic
for you to think that tackling a problem
is by
try to cuddle it how does that make any
sense that is that is the female it is
it really is you wouldn't see it that
way because you're a woman and I
understand men treats things completely
different a man is not going to come out
and see a boy selling drugs and she can
come and tell him oh I'm sorry I think
it's because of your upbringing no we're
going to point out the fact of the
matter I'm going to point out where he's
heading to which is probably going to
begin
you've seen only fans yeah the the
owners are only fans actually wanted to
wanted to shut it down they wanted to
clean it up and then there was a
campaign by women to stop it so because
they're the ones making money
because of the banks that was nothing to
do with them wanting to be like oh we
don't agree with this anymore okay okay
but what can I say to you it wasn't it
was women that went marching saying that
you're taking away all right it was
women it's the money you're taking no
I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying I'm
saying men own homes is hiring men own
only fans right so oh actually
homeschool my daughter on a McDonald's
wage maybe just don't have kids outside
of wedlock
the face is like it's like the oh no the
consequences of my own
fans girls is like you always at there's
so many jobs like I I don't know what
everybody else does here but I take it
there's only one only fans person here I
take it you're at University studying
because you're not going to do only fans
so I take it that whatever you're
studying I've actually thought of doing
early fan stuff okay that's fine that's
fine but I take it but I take it you're
not in University studying order to be
anything yeah no okay so whatever you're
studying is worth it's gonna is it worth
it's worthy self-study and it's gonna
pay for your life right but only fans is
a business
and then the same with men it's about
sacrifice are you willing to sacrifice
or you're going to go the easy Road
I'm just saying that
sometimes we decide that I'm gonna do
this because it will reap me a reward
hopefully in a given amount of time
right that's it so if you've got to
respect people they want the rewards
without the consequence of the backlash
that's what usually happens so that's
why when
you pull up receipts or you try to to
question their logic on why they do it
then it's always like oh you're
attacking me no no one is attacking you
it's just life comes with consequence
I'm not even speaking to you I'm just
saying in general yeah I'm saying like
as an only fans person I attack myself
every day for what I do I don't have to
do that babe don't let these people
think that what are you saying no
problem
no no no not you but I'm saying a couple
of people in here they do think that
they're better
you came in yourself
we can talk about better and worse
choices I'm not talking about you
exactly okay okay if I had a drug dealer
in here and we said why do you do that
you have a kid nobody would have the
same backlash yeah
very different
and I need you to not respond when I
talk I need you to shh thank you thank
you so it's selfish because it's not
supposed to be about you like what what
is money kids want good parents it is
absolutely selfish to put your kid in a
position where now they're gonna have to
see their parents having sex on the
internet I cannot because one day
because the truth comes out eventually
and one day kids grow up and people talk
and there's been there have there have
been wait wait there have been they're
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait thank you and there
have been there have been so many
accounts of kids that are getting
bullied because of their mother or their
father is on only fans
and it's and it's wrong
and it's no no no no nobody for being
black
bullied by not having people that don't
have enough money
that's so interesting come on you can't
make comparisons about when you see your
mom or your dad out there compared to
being bullied for being black that's not
a comparison
I can't be black today
can I ask you a question can I ask are
you black by choice no yeah that's what
I just said but are you can you actually
become a prostitute by choice no no no
hold on hold on hold on yes or no yes or
no yes or no no no don't hold don't call
her so guys
listen for all the Magnum that did pee
and stuff that went to school that did
Sports yeah you guys remember what was
like in the Pea room yeah all right I
want to ask everyone because you know
how else guys how did how do boys
violate each other
in football when we go ahead what
happens in the change rooms now the
reason I say this year is because that a
man would just say oh your mom before or
your mom's a whole that be enough to
make you stop beefing and scrapping just
in the playground let alone someone be
able to come and show them oh my God you
have no idea what that's going to do to
what I'm saying
no no no no it's not it's not
hypothetical no because it's all here no
no it's not here this is reality
no I'm not getting another thing is and
the thing is you guys want to do
everything and you guys want to live in
a world where there's going to be no
consequences but I'm telling you
something they are consequences
particularly when you have young men
like it's it's see a lot of women so we
speak about things so you you spoke you
said I always speak about single mothers
and the reason why I do is because is
because we have a lot of stats for
single parent homes and what they
produce and the upbrings of it it
doesn't mean all it's never all it's
never all it's majority but it's never
all so some people be raised by single
mother and they were going to be amazing
they're going to be like Marcus rashford
and feed the kids but for every Marcus
rashford on the estate there's loads of
people that are not going to make it out
to be Marcus rashford so all I'm trying
to say is sometimes when we speak as
well you take it so literally it's not
always all there's not always all that's
all it is and I've from and the reason I
want to go back to what I was saying to
Jim earlier on the reason I'm trying to
talk about protection is because you
don't understand that sometimes us men
will do protection a different way you
didn't see what I was doing in litter's
protection
just hold on a second but she didn't she
was talking about a gun but I was trying
to say the type of character that you
meet a man he does not know you he's
witnessed you kissing another man yeah
saying goodbye to him so I'm not trying
to move to you he's going to set in a
lift with you and carrying it looks nice
oh no no he's making an example get the
point get the point but you should get
the point no no but as women we need to
get the point that men are trying to
give us
and I said thank you
men wouldn't do anything so I said to
you what did I do in the lift and what
I'm trying to do is bring you my
character you've never met men wouldn't
do anything oh you know what you know I
said men wouldn't do anything if a woman
was in danger yeah of being her please
let me tell the story
okay okay guys guys guys guys guys wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
okay this is your last warning stop I've
told you to stop I'm still okay then get
out go go bye
foreign
yeah um with regards to I have a son and
he's an adult male now and he's coming
back from wherever and he's walking
and he saw a man hold a woman
and punch her in her face now he was
with another friend
and he said he moved so fast
and he went to that man and he held that
man and he said don't you ever in your
life
pick up your hand to another woman again
ever
and the woman was scared he wasn't going
to hit the man he just let him know
he didn't know who this woman was he
didn't know who the man was but it was
his Natural Instinct he didn't think he
said he moved so fast to that guy to let
him know that he could not put his hand
on that woman again
now that's what you call protection and
that's respect towards the other person
okay so sometimes I think we're not seen
sometimes we take men's language their
words and their demeanor
as aggression
and it's not aggression actually if we
would allow them to speak allow them to
make their point and for us to stop
being pseudo-masculine because that's
what I call it we've become so masculine
ourselves
that we're not realizing that sometimes
men are just being protective
we need to understand the nature of a
man
I think just listening to what's been
going on here I've seen it back and
forth
like some of the answers we are you know
how we are violent as women with our
mouths and our tongues facts we are so
disrespectful women mama I never said
just women I'm talking about
specifically what women do on this in
this um she's 60 like she's old enough
to be your mom she's seen life so can
you actually listen to her parents have
stayed in marriages that are not
beneficial I don't care can you can you
just listen to her you don't care about
age oh that's fine but can you listen to
her what country are you from wow I'm
Nigerian too like if you are actually
Nigerian yeah if you're actually
Nigerian you would be a little bit more
traditional communities
I've seen the detrimental so what you're
disrespecting an elder six year old
woman you don't know wow no she keeps on
talking I know you're talking over her
let her speak she's not representative
yeah I was raised in the Western World
Elders you don't yeah you don't think
there's some level of respect you just
give someone because they're a bit older
yeah I get that okay okay okay so I'm
not talking about your ethnicity so shh
go ahead basically I mean this is the
thing as as you know
men and women we have are natures and
often we're not trying to understand
each other's Natures women are trying to
change men and men do try to change
women I must I must say that but the
thing is why do we as women have to get
aggressive get defensive and then not
listen and then become personal why
the reason why is because like like so I
want to get back to what I'm trying to
say because she kept on interrupting it
so you guys will you guys make a lot of
um like brush statements that's fine you
can say what you want to say but when we
try to actually challenge it or give
information about you you want to start
over speaking us and they're making it
personal
um she wants to start speaking about
Pearl's legs and you want to start
asking what people do what you're doing
you're doing the conversation like it
really is not going to get us anywhere
like and the reason why I'm because we
can have real conversations about things
that we don't like necessarily agree on
we don't have to start making it
personal like but when you come here
with an agenda as you came with an
agenda the girl in the corner you want
to say you've seen me before you've seen
me on social media so you're whatever
you've seen of me in the clips you've
come with that Vim but you haven't seen
the full clip you haven't seen watch the
full episodes you have to understand
sure match that energy you matched how
you perceived you came in your Vibe was
very aggressive you was very is it is it
ever question is it possible that you
just miss like you you just took it the
wrong way no of course I mean I agree of
course this is is it is it possible as
women sometimes we take things the wrong
way there's not even a woman
and I'll tell you I'll tell you I'll
tell you something I've learned from
interviewing a lot of guys interviewing
hundreds of people a lot of times men
feel like they cannot talk to us because
they speak more direct and they're a
little bit harsher and they're a little
bit more to the point so when they speak
to us like they talk to other men then
we get offended and prissy and it's not
an aggressive thing it's not that
they're trying to come at you they just
speak directly and you're so used to
most women are so used to having men
cater to them and a lot of simp guys
around them speaking generally yes
mostly it's simp guys talking to you
like a woman and so when you say oh it's
how you say it it's your tone you're
saying hey communicate to me like a
woman men do not talk like that if I do
if I was to talk direct to a guy or be
very serious then you would say oh she's
masculine you're very masculine you've
been doing that and I don't care I don't
give a but see it says you're
swearing wow can I correct this is how
your Nigerian parents raise you can I
just can I are you insane let me correct
something
a woman a woman cannot be masculine she
can be pseudo-masculine a man can be
masculine you're insane of course you
can't be masculine because when she said
what are you gonna do if I actually got
up and then she said oh what you could
and the reason I'm just trying to say is
no man would do that because I would get
up and do something sure and and the
thing about this is this is what I'm
trying to say whoever raised her
disgusting upbringing because you're mad
disgusting
disgusting out I'd have to watch my
channel
I'm a podcaster I'm a podcast
he's not only fans though
I'm talking more money than him that's
that's the problem
I can I can attest wait wait wait wait
wait I can't wait I can I can attest
watching the lifespan of only fans
models none of them are good with money
they're broke out like it's only like
only like uh I don't remember the exact
number but like five to ten percent make
it after 40 they age out and then but
it's not even that it's just even when
someone's like oh you got more like what
what it's always so I wanted to show you
guys a video because um we said that
like men don't know it's always the dead
things that always move like that I've
realized that
it's kind of interesting when she was
insulting him about his money that
nobody really had that reaction but if
he goes for her looks like she she can't
she can't yeah he she came at him first
like yeah
she got money and she's ugly so there's
a difference
and she's actually ugly so
Jesus Christ okay um so I have a video
I'm gonna show okay so um she said that
men don't protect women I had a feeling
these two
I'm sorry I'll be honest with you yeah
you have to get rid of them too so maybe
we can have some conversations because
all they wanted to do was try to come at
me yeah she saw me from the social media
so she thought she could come and try to
attack me and I've realized this I am
really that relevant I've realized in
this last two weeks bro I am so relevant
within the UK all the major blocks post
me people recognize me so when people
see me I'm not even gassed up I mean I'm
gonna talk my so when people see me
now they want to come at me I just got
monetized she's telling me you're just a
YouTuber
okay so we wanted to talk about how men
um and I'm pretty sure I hope this is
the right video because I just pulled
this up on my phone
um you know women I think a lot of times
walk around in la la land and I call it
La La Land because women in general
don't have to face reality till we're
about like 45 there's a couple hot ones
that make it after yeah because the
world's just nicer to you because you're
pretty and young all of us yeah yeah
yeah I mean that is a thing there's such
things
women women hit 18 were born with value
the men are nicer to us we get special
jobs and privileges then the beauty goes
and then that's when you see all the
women going crazy at like 45 they're
like ah you you look great though you
don't you don't look sick you don't look
like incredible
but one of the things I think women have
this idea at night that we like we can't
we don't get this protection it's so
scary for us but really it's much
scarier for the men and they did a
social experiment where a woman was
hitting a man in public and a man was
hitting a woman in public and I hope
this is the right video I think it is
but let me let me show you guys what
happened
foreign
[Music]
today we're doing the domestic violence
experiment I'm going to be abusing him
he's going to be abusing me and we're
going to see who gets more attention
he's talking to him last night
listen
listen yeah listen you could tell me the
truth
you could tell me the truth why are you
talking to that guy last night I wasn't
listen don't talk to God
why are you stopping
we're filming a social experiment
look look no no you okay we're just
awareness I'm just listen we're just
filming bro now we're filming a social
experiment
sure man thanks for raising awareness
man we're filming a social experiment
for domestic violence thanks a lot man
right yeah me too yeah yeah I know it's
a great time they do stuff yeah
I don't know about you but it's about to
attack you right now yeah thanks a lot
though
thank you guys switched up look we're
filming thank you guys
thank you thank you for saying something
we're filming
just for domestic violence
[Music]
I wasn't cheating at you
on the ground
thoughts about this I'm not trying to
minimize I I really think it's good that
there's more Spotlight on violence
against men I definitely think it's an
issue that should be brought to light
and should be addressed and should be
you know spoken to but biologically
speaking right A man is not going to
inflict I mean a woman is not going to
inflict the same amount of damage
so what is the great equalizer freaking
knife no I feel like no one should touch
anyone no right right but it just made
out of excuse me
the first thing you said was not even to
talk about the issue it was just like
you know but you know women
how would you how would you determine
which gender is more violent
the way I would determine it is who
commits violence against people that
don't deserve it
now I know what you're thinking like you
know
um so like when men fight there's
usually a reason right there's usually
like maybe they disrespected each like
there's usually something behind it
right like I don't know I know gangs go
at each other I'm not saying they're
good reasons but they're reasons right
but when you look at children and the
elderly women are more likely to kill
both
I would argue women are more violent
yeah if uh if a direct parent kills
their kid so that means like it's their
blood uh 90 chance it's the mother
I mean even if we look at you know
people of their thoughts on abortion one
out of three women have had an abortion
yeah but I say women kill women kill
their babies the most so yeah they the
most likely the most likely person to
kill a baby in the first year is its own
mother of course and this has been like
a phenomenon even before like modern
times
and things like that this you know
there's some psychological stuff
excusing it but yeah yeah but I mean we
could even okay let's look at the
elderly it's the same thing
in terms of their women are much more
likely to kill the elderly
I think I think the point is
that okay guys NHS that nurse how many
murders did you just get get done for so
we can't China
what I would say is that both men and
women are violent why not just leave it
at that we're violent for different
reasons and in different ways
the thing is I think I wouldn't say
mostly I I would say that we we can both
be well I just think whenever there's
like a stat that makes us look bad I've
just noticed it's always like why are we
comparing
no but but generally generally I think
of that I think that the way people talk
about masculinity as though like men are
very inherently violent I think that the
thing is that
life is just like survival of the fetus
right and you see like with lesbian
relationships I think that women are not
just as violent as men because they
don't have the opportunity to correct
right now now after you check the stats
thoughts you know you know like whatever
um lesbian relationships domestic
violence is more yeah three men will
abuse you when they know that they can
biologically though obviously may have
testosterone so there will be more
so guys the thing about this thing right
here they've all they've always been
Violent Men do you guys keep talking
about men men have always done the most
violence but the difference was you was
protected by the group you was protected
by your brother your uncle or your man
or your father right and then up until
the point you got married you protected
by them and then we have police so now
you're protected by the police you are
not old safety I'm not old safety I've
been stabbed before I've been shot at
before most of my friends can be stabbed
before when you women when she was
talking about oh it's safer for do you
know how dangerous it is for us men when
we speak about
um all the stabbings and stuff it's not
women getting stabbed it's very
dangerous for for young black men
particularly and it's not even dangerous
because you're doing anything like you
could just be walking in the long ends
and the man says where you from cause
and that's it and you women don't
understand that violence
you've got Brothers here so even when it
comes down to this so when you speak
about oh oh it's more dangerous for
women yes in some aspects it is but us
man we we realize that if I walk danger
if I walk late at night someone might
Jack me someone tried to move to me
video is more dangerous I respect the
fact that in both genders actually it's
just as dangerous leaving at any time
okay cool okay even throughout the day
what I'm saying with you what I will say
to you is you've got that thing that my
sister had but it came at age where I
told her to stop doing that because you
start dealing with men that don't care
about your sister they don't care about
like when you deal with the role they
don't care about your mother they don't
care about none of this if you could see
it up that's it on site to be fair no
one does outside your house huh no one
does no one cares about you yeah so it's
not fees for women to say you know what
like I'm I'm gonna do what you do
because more time man will do you the
same way well and the whole point is
like women act like they can't walk like
they're like oh I can't walk home alone
at night no one can't like that's the
whole point like we live in such a safe
we live in such a safe world that we we
think like we we have we're so we live
in this la la land where we feel like
we're entitled to safety do you know
because we should be though I I think no
I would say I would actually say no not
anymore
why not because you know I think safety
goes back to traditionalism and feminism
is what's the norm now women want to be
equal so be equal and if you can't be
equal that means you have to give up
some power to the men
which is what men women getting abused
no that's not what I said
what do you mean by that so you need to
get something okay which is okay so I'll
give you an example I I don't believe
this is a you know a popular opinion
everyone know I don't know if you guys
do but I don't think women should vote
and the reason I don't think women
should vote is because in the U.S
um we vote for the commander-in-chief so
that's that's the leader of the army he
decides if they go to war right and the
thing is when a man turns 18 he cannot
vote if he is not enrolled in Selective
Service selective Services kind of like
the draft but Jace basically means in
war times if goes south yeah you
got you got to go to war you have no
choice I think until women want to do
the same thing
which then then you don't get the same
rights right but vote and that's what I
know is that um War because I've got my
own yeah you've got my own agreement to
some of the things you said that are
also controversial okay do you mean war
or do you mean
which what do you mean so can you say
the question a different way okay so for
example you just said now
I'll base it on like let's say hormones
for example yeah okay are you saying
that women shouldn't vote because based
on those types of decisions
I have a couple different I have a
couple different reasons for it so the
first is that like women I think if you
want the equal Freedom then you have to
have the equal responsibility or equal
work I agree so if you want all of I
think if you want all the free like okay
if you have a house and you want to do
whatever that you want in the house
right I think you should pay the bills
isn't that or at least put on an equal
load or put on an equal load is the men
and they're also looking after their
kids too so and that's actually wrong
have you heard which actually so I'm
gonna wait wait overweight so women if
we look at Society like imagine society
as a house okay women aren't building
anything in society we're not building
the houses we're not we're not running
the factories that build the phones the
electron like none of the super hard
jobs women are doing you could say
teaching nursing is a hard job but not
compared to like an oil rate you mean
like direct to CEOs that type of thing
they're not no none of these structure
that we need so you can you could argue
you know because there's a lot of stress
that comes like the Fortune 500 CEOs
like most women wouldn't want to do
those jobs those jobs are like you don't
have a life I've interviewed some of
those guys oh trust me like you we don't
want to do that it's so funny because
women always say oh we are not fortunate
500 i'm like you don't want to be
but anyways anyway so we we look at all
the hardest jobs in society women aren't
doing them on top of that we're a net
tax loss that means we spend more money
than we make okay so were the majority
of the ones on benefits and yet we're
the biggest voting block so I just don't
think it's fair when we pay less taxes
we're not the ones going to war and we
do the least amount of work that we have
the most to say and the politicians all
make policies for us
right but we're both we're both living
in a world so obviously it shouldn't
only men be voting because women are
living here as well so obviously they
should be allowed allowed to say oh
what's going on I mean I think we should
we maybe I could like you know I've
heard a couple different like ideas
where it's only women that are net
taxpayers only women that are enrolled
in the military like but my point is and
I just think we need to do equal work so
either be a net taxpayer fine be in the
military finite I'd also argue the
crackheads down the street shouldn't
vote either you know what I mean like
why do they get a say but the thing is
most of women nowadays are basically
crackheads they're like in debt we're in
a ton of debt
um you know we don't really do any of
the hard jobs we have a lot of and
that's why I wasn't even trying to come
at her when I said we chose to do
anything and we're only fans models
statistically that's true but when we
have more women picking only fans and
that doesn't even include the women that
are Instagram models right and basically
are doing prostitution so it's probably
if I had to guess I'd guess five to ten
percent of women are doing this under
the age of 30 35 so this is what we're
picking to do we're picking the easy
stuff that's just what we pick so my
thing is why do we get the same say
like that's that's my argument I feel
like whenever someone does get a choice
to do something easier over to male or a
female you'll choose the easiest right
well no I think that's a female thing
actually because because men like men
pick hard jobs because they know
someone's got to do it and and they
don't have the same options as us
sometimes we think that one that's true
but we do as women if we're If we're
honest and fair you know as a woman okay
I'm no longer 18 but you know if I'm 18
or 20 I know I can put on a mini skirt
some high heels and maybe scope out
where um footballers are all oh my God
wherever and you know get myself hooked
up and become a wife a trophy one facts
though and it's facts and then and I
could live the good life but the man now
from 18 he's got to graft and maybe by
the time he's 30 you know he would have
made enough money maybe maybe exactly
45. Hey listen you know what it is well
and the other thing is the men they they
used to give protection but they got
something in return so they would say
hey okay we're gonna we're gonna give
you all you women together we will
protect you we will die for you but you
give us children and you give us Purity
so we're virgin your virgins on our
wedding day and you give us they used to
have 7.2 kids for every woman now we're
not even having enough kids to replace
the population we're not having seven
kids
but this is well and this is the point
we don't really have traditional women
anymore
and that's and that's kind of a
conversation we have to have in society
like what what is it moving forward are
we gonna are we gonna push policies that
make us more equal so we we have to go
into the military or are we going to
give up freedoms
biologically you know we literally it
can't be 50 50 the military you did say
um I think it was trying to actually
that said that that men wouldn't even
put women in the front lines correct
that you feel like a woman could protect
you on the front line be honest
you're missing the point because we
don't think women will be able to
protect us that's why we are fighting
against it but it's the women that are
still trying to fight back and say no we
want to protect you by all means
necessary we're telling you logically it
doesn't make sense it's the same thing
with the conversation of
um um when she said nothing's
transgender and nothing is um
traditional anymore you went into the
toilet I saw a man who are the majority
that are supporting that is it men or
women women
to hide no no it's like um the trans
movement it's actually mostly women
no because they're pushing an agenda
that they know they can use it
what is the problem you don't want to
listen the reality is in this life since
the beginning of time there has always
been an elite group that have seeked to
control the population for their
personal benefits and they will stop at
nothing to get what they want now what
is happening is that because back in the
day at least women had no choice if you
if you were on your own you would die so
women had to work with men but now men
have built the world and giving you all
this safety and now you've turned your
backs on the very same man that gave you
this safety
[Applause]
you've turned your backs on this same
man that built this world for you to
sideways that you're speaking about so
you're generalizing yes I am generalized
can I give you an example I mean all
three women in here thought they were
entitled to tell men how to talk
that's yes yes sorry sorry you all were
talking about their tone that's telling
man because
if you feel disrespected are you gonna
say anything
wait wait wait wait I know I just I okay
did you see me getting all mad when she
was insulting me I mean did you see let
me see your juice because no no because
because no no no no no no no no no no no
I didn't do it in the beginning when I
started the shows because my mom raised
me to not react but the thing is we have
a bunch of women that didn't have a
strong masculine fathers in the home
yeah I had the bad have the best dad on
the planet he always told me like do not
get mad just stay calm and that's it and
and it's like women think they like just
because you feel a certain way you're
entitled to act how you want and and no
yeah and and that's the thing right you
can always tell who I say you can always
tell who someone's been raised by
because throughout this whole time I've
been provoked I've been prodded I've
been called aggressive I've been
insulted I've thought you guys have done
everything you can do to poke the BET
and if I was a lesser man if I was a man
that didn't care about women I could I
could react and I'm just trying to show
you the double standard I had a woman
tell me what you're gonna do you're
giving sassy like do you see that
language
I want to point out one thing too it's
like they left the room was calm yeah
but even when that happened no no but
like you're you're having it what does
it say if he's here now you guys are
here none of you are offended it was
them too yeah
and it's funny because you guys were so
quick to defend them when you I know
deep down you know he wasn't you know he
wasn't I didn't defend okay so here's
the thing I was going like this
but what I'm saying is yeah what you
guys did is a collective thing what you
women do when you women get together you
see you feel like your periods your
vaginas are lying you so when you when
there's a Madness
you don't want a vagina
I had three sisters and a mother I grew
up in a hospital of women I know how it
is right I am see China exclude me sorry
I'm very very thank you yes sorry sorry
sorry but I'm very passionate I'm very
masculine and the reason I say this is
because they try what I am is what they
try to push out yeah strong men that are
willing to speak up you guys normally
all pretty women in here you normally
have men that Panda to you that Pitter
Pat around you because they normally
want something I don't want anything
from up from any of you women other than
the conversation that we can learn more
about each other I can learn something I
can take and I can grow right and the
audience can get some
so when I come around women I will tell
you about yourself because I don't I'm
not I don't want not only fans go I'm
not I'm I ain't no Fanboy and and that's
right and the thing is like women
respond really quickly to social shame
I'll give you an example I did um my
show um Pearl daily I like cover the
news every day it's gonna Premiere after
this guys let's see what
yeah
but I reacted today to a girl that lived
in Japan for a year and she was like
this is what I used to wear in America
it was like leggings the tight stuff and
she's like guys do not wear this in
Japan like I do not do it and she showed
her outfit in Japan it was like these
running basketball shorts with leggings
underneath and like a tight top so women
respond really quickly to social shame
so a lot of times when men are shaming
you like four things it's because
they're trying to protect you and you
know what I was yeah well I would even
try to shame her I don't know if
anyone's seen well the thing is you
could you shame comes from within yeah
like you nobody can make you feel
whatever you guys will not say it's true
black guys I never called that any I
didn't call it out of her name I did I
literally I didn't speak about all I
said wow you got a daughter and you do
only fans that's four
guys
yeah like you this is the other thing
that like women want to poke the bear
and get mad when they I agree I agree I
very much agree with him broke she calls
she said she hated he hated black women
and you like women just want to poke
poke poke and then when she said that
and I got mad and she said oh you're
getting mad how dare you you don't know
my upbring you don't know who my father
is you know my relationship with my
sisters and my nieces and then you tell
me I hate black women because I'm
talking about black women's hair and
what Society has done now here's the
point here's the point what it is is
that when you start to say things that
prick
you understand then women get very very
difficult how is that fair to me it's
not no it's not it's not true yeah yeah
but we are unfair as women no but we we
have to face that truth no but we don't
care about men's mental health
please let me finish it is true you just
said it we don't care enough about men's
feelings we do not and a lot of the time
in the environment that we've been
raised we've been made to feel that
we're entitled to speak to men in a
certain way and that if they respond to
us oh now they're aggressive but I want
what I'm here is trying I'm trying to
say men have feelings too you know well
not just some you guys say oh men should
go men are scared too you know what you
think we just want to go to some random
group of people and we can't get have
you ever can I ask a question has any of
you guys ever been stabbed here before
has any of you guys ever been on Live
support machine before no I have I know
what it feels like so we're not but it's
not what I'm trying to say to you and
that came from an argument over a car
park space it had nothing to do with are
you listening oh car park space an
argument and I got stabbed and put on
life support machine you women don't
understand violence you don't yeah
so when I say everyone okay
I'm generalizing if it's not you please
I'm not throwing it at you I'm saying
generalized women don't understand
violence because when you were speaking
early on you had no idea what can happen
so when I said to him would you say to
me what she said no I said to King and
the reason they want because they know
automatically it's gonna that's a beef
response but women are safe Society the
place the studio has made you feel safe
and the fact that I'm a nice guy yeah
and she knows it deep down that's why
she did it because if she felt like I
was actually gonna do something there's
no way she would have done that and then
guess what I would have been the bad guy
I do not disagree with you my brothers
yeah so my two youngest ones okay I'll
talk about a conversation from my
youngest one yeah for example he came to
me he knows all everybody all of my
family knows not to put your hand on a
woman you just don't you don't put your
hand in a woman some deserving
it
I'll talk on that my brother came to me
and said right well what happens in a
scenario where there's a girl coming at
me and she is literally throwing fists
antagonizing me like he said poke in the
bear I said at that point if someone's
got their hand on your throat or
punching up is self-defense
I don't respect if you just because you
think you're a woman and this is where I
said sometimes it may sound like I'm
agreeing with you in some respects but I
do feel like you need to know your place
you are not stronger than a man yeah and
you shouldn't be antagonizing a man
that's bigger and stronger even if he's
smaller than you a Shortcake
not your child you
you child
news getting killed by their girlfriends
like that that only fans modeled blonde
chick yeah
abuse is abuse we need to but and also I
want to touch on something you said I
wouldn't say as women that don't don't
acknowledge the fact that mental men's
mental health is is something as a
society that we need to recommend that
reinforce it a bit more though you need
to respect yourself actually I'll
actually tell you what what my take on
on mental health is I I actually think
men have mental health problems because
women tell them to communicate like
women and they're not I agree on that so
they'll tell men to be like more in
touch with their feelings and talk about
their problems and men just don't
communicate they won't raise like that
I've had conversations with my friends
I've had my conversation with my friends
where they're saying why doesn't he did
it how does he not know to just call me
and why wouldn't he ask me and I said
because he's not you he doesn't think
like you the Jazz you guys literally
told police me this whole time but also
this is the problem that's why we're
different we're not the same I always
like to pick up on the very little
things you said they weren't raised like
that men shouldn't be raised like that
that's the point it's because I'll tell
you why I'll tell you why testosterone
is an action hormone it's not there to
sit around and talk about its feelings
it's there to go out and do things
literally in the Bible the Bible gave
two curses he gave a curse to the woman
he gave a curse to the man the man's
course was to go out and toward the
Earth
it doesn't make any sense
never speak about his feelings but
a man should only decide to start
talking about his feelings after he has
gone out to to put out action not before
so and this is the difference between
men and women because women we feel
better when we talk about the problem
men feel better when they solve it yes
so them talking about the problem
doesn't make them feel better they just
want to figure out why are different and
yeah like you said yep is it was King
King mentioned the Bible if we're going
to mention the Bible let's wrap it all
up here then what do you mean well
because the Bible if we're going to base
it on that then then don't just take
what you want from it look at all of it
in the Bible specifically
the Bible specifically talks about
gender roles does it not yeah let's not
pick and choose then don't pick it when
it suits you the Bible talks about them
and the woman being what the home raises
and whatever which is what you're
basically saying all right let's do that
but boys women that have decided to
leave the home yeah women don't want
women
Everything's changed
you literally just said who's pushing
out those kids you just said that yeah I
can't push out seven but I won't be
pushing our kids how many I will be God
willing okay okay so I have a question
do you do you believe in obeying your
husband and all yeah I do but that's
because I'm a Christian but that's
because it depends on what and this is
why I said can I just say that's why I
said you can't generalize it comes down
to the individual so that's why I don't
like talking on you women this year
because I don't speak like the next
person so you need to speak
but here's the thing so if we want to
see how traditional Society is you
really can look at two metrics right
and really these are all down to the
women and the women's choices so the
more traditional societies tend to have
higher birth rates so um for example
like right now it's roughly one point
like eight 1.5 I think UK
um and you go to a bit more traditional
countries like in Africa like it's like
four I think in Nigeria
um roughly right and and the other stat
you can look at is the average age of
first marriage so here it's 31 when it's
younger it's typically more traditional
those two choices are the women's women
do not we do not want to be traditional
because when we have the most Beauty and
the most youth we don't pick marriage
all right so what's your take on um
marriage when for example girls 13 years
old
13. okay you said you said you said
young marriages that's traditionally
traditionally
um I think 13 is a bit young
but please I just want to clarify I just
want to clarify what I was saying
because the reality is yeah I'm I was
born Catholic I was raised Christian as
well but the reason why I brought that
Bible verse is not because it's not
because I wanted to take a religious
angle because you wanted to make it like
okay if you want to speak religious no
everything I'm saying is actually rooted
in biology it's not even just about
religion and I can give you an example I
can debunk what you just said right now
if yeah if we're to take away because
she said she doesn't believe and you're
like oh we shouldn't generalize we can't
generalize the reason why she can have a
choice to say well no I don't do this
and you can have a different opinion is
because of the society we have built as
men if we're to take away this Society
every single woman will revert back to
her natural programming and she will
look for a man to be under his
protection yeah probably but exactly
that's the fact not everything
you can't just have a discussion
no because no because no because
I said exactly what I said wait wait
wait wait I wanna I wanna I wanna I
wanna point something out where again
he's being very direct with you and
you're telling him how to talk I'm
saying as a whole even I've heard men do
it to you and say oh you triggered
because she's speaking from an emotional
standpoint so let's not do that but I'm
just saying I'm not
you literally said something and what
you said I wanted to correct it because
it changed the point I was trying to
remember that's what I was saying yes
because I made a point on what you said
try to change the point so is that not
changing how I no pearl was just trying
to illustrate something that's going
back and forth and if you could catch
what she was trying to say then it might
be something you could take on about me
telling him how to talk to me I didn't
tell him I talked to me
right but I'm saying you just told him
that it's not a debate so you're saying
he can't debate you but he was just
talking to you and you took it as a
debate and even if yeah and even if I
was debating you were literally on a
podcast to debate so yeah do what you
want that's fine then all right exactly
so that's the point so like I made a
point but you're trying to you're trying
to pick holes in my my Approach when you
can just talk I wanna I wanna point out
something that men like kind of look for
and like this is what so it's like you
know we'll get the Christian chicks that
come on and they'll say oh I'll obey my
husband in all things and when a guy
tells them something they don't listen
yeah perfectly that's not my mind you
know okay no but this is the thing like
traditionalism and like true like true
traditionalism
you acknowledge that all men are born
with respect like like that you have to
obey all men to some level because they
built the society they protect us and
now women just feel like entitled to but
the funny thing is I might not even be
her man but literally the way the human
being did and this is so it's so funny
the way the human mind works is you
literally do what you practice so I
might not be your man but trust me I
don't think I mean I might be wrong but
you might get you might find yourself in
a marriage and find yourself doing the
exact same thing so so so my thing with
this is like it's like
it's like
you don't I don't want to put it I don't
want to put it slap
and I've had I had just this isn't even
not I'm not trying to take a dig at you
but I've just had so many hundreds of
like super like Christian chicks come on
and it actually kind of makes me sad
with the state of the church because
like there's just so few that that like
I I really think are obedient to men
like like and I'm telling you I've had
600 plus chicks on here probably at
least a hundred dollars
wait okay wait I'm wait wait this isn't
about you but I'm saying like when when
women come in and they say like Oh I'm a
Christian so I believe in submitting
it's like I don't know what they're
teaching in churches I just don't think
it's something
I'm actually Christian and yeah and I'm
married right so oh yeah
do I want to clap for you
oh are you leaving them that's my wife
though yeah
um um so basically I I understand the
perspective but biblically women were
not actually instructed to obey all men
right but by understand where you are
coming from culturally right biblically
women will
we're only um you know um um demanded to
submit to their husbands right now that
does not mean that that you should be
sassy or root to any other person even
in general right but but I just needed
to point that out because
um I think that there is quite a
difference between cultural you know
conservativeness or traditionalism
you submit to your boss you submit to
Authority and Society yeah yeah
definitely and I'm saying on some base
level like men used to have a base level
of authority that they had in society
just because they were a man yeah you
know I feel like I I feel like it's like
so
I don't have to you don't have to be my
girl see let me bring you back to what
happened in the lift I had not nothing
to do with that woman but yeah look how
I treated her look how I treated a woman
because she's a woman right yeah like
would you not do that for a man no I'm
saying I would treat him with respect
yeah automatically because he's a man
and I don't want to disrespect a man
just like I'll treat a woman with a
level of care if all both of these girls
that violated me here today disrespected
me if I was downstairs now when I saw
something happen I'm going to jump in
I'm going to jump in because they women
and because how I was raised I'm it's
not because yeah and that's like you
give you give women a baseline
protection yeah men in general give
women a baseline protection but women
but women don't give man a baseline
respect just because they're men and so
when she was talking about oh if man
come in here I'm not going to talk about
what I've been through we don't have to
talk about that but I just said to what
happened in the lift she didn't want to
say it because she got in the lift and
she was about to have a panic attack 21
floors up I literally made a stand there
look at your toes Breathe In and Out
count and then we got to the 21st floor
ask Omar you sure hug me yeah
so for my finger was like it was like
like you even don't understand that us
man do a base type of security and a
base type of protection you don't
realize that but you just go out in the
world and we don't get that type of
protection we honestly don't get that
type of protection and it's just you
don't realize that even when you speak
to him and he's not your man how you're
I don't know your man could be watching
you this is a big platform you know your
husband probably watching this right now
he's watching shout out
[Laughter]
okay well I'm saying like but you know
literally this is a big platform your
mind might be saying you don't want to
make it to housewife today and get
married to her but he's watching it's
even like her time it's even it's even
her talking there when I was like wait
wait wait it's like you don't have to be
invited here and yet she still felt like
she she should be able to over talk me
just because she's here and Usman Usman
we hate that but we love feminine energy
and
I'm I'm part of the thing is you women
get way more out of men being do you
know some women do you know them girls
that just get everything out a man you
must know them girl that they never they
never asked me also and also
why is that but why is that I'm not
going to say because they do nothing mad
but generally don't those girls that
tend to we said it earlier pretty
privilege but there's some people ego is
it's not just pretty I think it's more
than pretty pretty no that's it's about
time I give it attitude it's about the
fact that they give their man respect
it's about the way they treat them the
way they speak to them
girls that get everything out of their
mind I think I think I'm illustrating
maybe a man just wants to make his
girlfriend happy but why what are you
doing
you don't know maybe she cooks for her
maybe she cleans for him yeah maybe
she's birthing children okay you know
she gives them emotional support he
comes home okay and this sounding good
to me yeah okay
maybe she takes him out okay and she
gives them four
I know you think she deserves that if
she does if she yeah if she does that I
think she does yes so don't you think
other women could do that and be a
deservant as she is yes not everyone
wants to do that some some women don't
want to cook some of them don't want to
clean and I think that's okay but that's
a person yeah they need to find a man
that would be okay with that that's what
I'm saying what else I think is mostly
because she respects him it's not even
because she does all of that it's
respect maybe she just wants to make you
happy as well she literally maybe just
I'm telling you the reason why the man
gives her everything is not because of
all those things she's doing it's
probably because even on top of the fact
that she does all of that she still
respects him and treats him like the man
of the house imagine this all those guys
that you were talking about in Tesco's
they all have families the people that
are cleaning the streets they'll have
families that respect them every single
day and it's and this man built the
world like you guys don't see these guys
because you go every single day you
don't see these guys you literally walk
past them but you know what next time
you're on the you know you're driving on
the train or something night time like
whatever it's just look just look look
at the guys you know have a look at
these are the guys that are literally
literally it's on if you break down in
your car tomorrow who's gonna come out
from 8
to be a woman might be nice okay
and if it was a woman there'd be nothing
wrong with it but the chances are it's
not going to be a woman right it's going
to be a man that's going to be picking
up from the side and you're gonna be
very happy to see that man right but
let's not miss that beautiful point that
he just made about respect I think
sometimes we forget what respect really
means even the way you look at your man
eye to eye contact as a woman sometimes
it could be so disrespectful you know
that look when you look down
as opposed to a look where you look at
him and you respect him and he knows
that when he goes out to work I'm not
saying the woman's not working okay but
he knows that you respect what he does
you respect who he is yeah you respect
what he brings to the table and I think
sometimes we forget that have you ever
looked at someone and they just I don't
I'm not going to hurt my friend but the
way his Mrs looks at him like remember
no I'm not gonna hurry up but she looks
at him like he's the only man who is the
only but you've never like looking up a
man like that when I want to have a man
no I'm saying like like yeah but for how
long
but it depends on what he does
that's me
like don't want to go looks at you like
she looks no but she looks at him like
yo that's right
and when people talk about marriage you
know it's a painful feeling for me for
me I don't prescribe to the Western
ideology marriage especially now after
doing this for a year
oh man yeah they were in my eye they
ruined my idea of marriage but for me
as long as you have your union like you
got like you guys say actually I
actually think that like men would take
respect over everything everything over
the cooking that clean oh cool does that
matter too yes yes yeah don't cook for
me
to the respect though do you not think
that's respect as well so like you're
doing like something for your man no
obviously like I can I said to um my guy
as well I said does it not I had an
actual argument of him I said does it
not matter that you've got someone that
can cook and can do all these things but
he's like no no I was like what oh what
do you mean he's like I'm with you
because of you I had a mind-blowing
experience I was like well because every
man I had been with before that yeah had
made me feel like I'm not enough unless
I can do this and I can do that and tick
this box and take that one I wasn't
enough just being mean
I respect that much
I look at him like how you said because
of that mutual respect I don't have to
be more than that okay okay do you know
where did you meet him just remember
you said you want to escape
and oh look at how the energy has
changed now in the room yeah because
it's really talk you can respect both
sides can I say something quickly so you
know what I think I feel like a man no
matter what you do for me can do
everything clean and cook but if he
doesn't respect you or what you do it
just doesn't matter so I feel like the
mutual respect that that is their
Foundation at the end of the day I'm
Mutual I actually I don't think so I I
think like men they love women and women
respect men agree with yeah I agree like
like I think that like usually when
women feel like that I just think he
doesn't like them
um
maybe if he likes what he does for her
for him but he doesn't actually like her
yeah well I mean you know I don't know
how familiar you guys are with the
content but I mean you know it's like
basically
most women in their 20s are sleeping
with like 20 percent of men
twenty percent yeah yeah okay I just
have a question raise your hand have you
ever been cheated on anyone yeah one two
three okay okay yeah so pretty much me
too it's all right you know it's all
right it's all right but it's like it's
like it's because you know women's
requirements are so high that it's a
very small percentage of men so if you
want to go over six foot that's fifteen
percent of men you want a guy that makes
over like 70 even just 70
000 pounds a year which is lower than a
lot of women say you know that's only
ten percent of men so if you have a guy
that's in one of those categories like
most women don't realize there's a line
yeah if he's good looking like women
find 80 of men as unattractive not okay
not decent looking so if you have you if
you see a guy and you think he's cute
and you actually just think oh he's cute
he's probably top 10 20 of men you're
speaking to me bro yeah yeah yeah I
guess
yeah yeah but so the problem is you have
girls that are like on a one to ten one
we're never honest with each other about
our ratings so most women have an
inflated ego where they think they're
hotter than they are so you got girls
that are fives sixes sevens eights all
sleeping with the tens all sleeping with
the eights nines and tens and then the
women come out and they're like oh I
hate men I hate men but it's like it's
because like when a girl says that it's
just because she's been like sleeping
with the top 20 percent they share baby
Fathers as well so one guy will have
right right yeah yeah it's a thing but
they're right there's a reason for it
right like even historically most men
haven't even reproduced like it's only
been uh I think uh 40 percent of men
have replay historically so there's
always been two women for one man but
yeah and so that's why a lot of times
people think I advocate for cheating and
it's funny because they say women don't
have any power women are oppressed but
the funny thing is women are the reason
why we are where we are today women are
the ones that have selected the genes
that have survived Through Time women
are the ones that control who gets born
yes
they say women are oppressed so if and
and like I said even if you look at the
stats most people in the western world
are raised by single mothers right so
even the men you complain about are
being raised by women
so these are the conversations that we
need to start having but whenever we try
to have them they always tell like that
girl said oh yo I'm not demonizing
single mothers right but we have stats
right so when single mothers do good we
praise them we we praise them a strong
independent woman single mothers but
when they do bad and we try to critique
them all of a sudden with the demons so
yeah if you don't like the men that are
being raised if you're saying the
comment men are abusive if you're saying
the emotional if you're saying all of
these things then we need to look at who
is Raising and then and the thing is
what I had I had like kind of a and this
is why you know all these chicks get so
mad that I advocate for virginity you
um weren't you the one that was like
Pearl are you that's always what they do
they get triggered I think I thought it
might have been her it was foreign
I thought it was you but it's okay okay
sorry okay so but the reason I advocate
where I say you know a lot of problems
would be fixed if men married virgins
okay they're like Pearl like isn't that
in the hypocritical whatever but I
started looking at the data okay women
that have five sexual partners guess
what person well guess what percent go
on to have a happy marriage how much 20
to 25 percent will have a happy marriage
if you're a virgin on your wedding day
guess guess what percent will have a
happy marriage 70 to 80 roughly
depending on this do you men actually
want to wait that's a different combo
but I'm gonna get to that okay so what
happened was I I started looking at
basically every problem in society
homelessness mental health School
shooters all that is linked to
promiscuous women because they tend to
leave marriages so then create single
mother homes or do only fans and like
get pregnant by someone whatever so
basically all of society's problems are
really from us women being promiscuous
maybe yeah yeah yeah and so you want to
talk about the the Virgin thing right
the issue is again before our dads would
help us so our dads would say when the
eight nine and ten guy came by and most
of her dads still will we just don't
listen No but like the eight nine and
ten guy will come by and say I'm trying
with your daughter her and the dad would
be like oh no stay away from that boy
you know there's a reason they used to
have songs about that now we have
unlimited access we said we want to pick
ourselves so we went off to college we
said let's go pick and we choose
terrible we make that's why I think
women aren't that smart because like
what what do we pick for today
before you get what's the most important
decision that you can make the father of
your kids and now my question is do we
make good decisions always not always
would you say more of us make good
decisions with boyfriends and partners
or bad decisions bad man okay okay so so
I so that's why and I don't say it to
hate on women but it's just like I think
we're more emotional so we don't make
good decisions I think the thing here is
to educate
ourselves in a different way probably
not put everyone down and say you're
dumb you're not smart enough to do this
but Empower us in a way that can be like
be smart
I don't have the courage to leave make
better decisions so but here's the thing
like again I just to me it's like women
we just don't get it and I just think we
used to they used to kind of say that
women were dumb they used to make jokes
about it
yeah yeah and I think we should I think
we should bring it back that's why I'm
leading the movement I I don't know and
I don't think it's and this is you know
you know this is coming from someone
honestly I've Gotten Good at everything
I've tried at to be honest and so I'm
not saying no women can or there aren't
smart women but as a group we don't make
good decisions I think we make emotional
emotions
because because for five minutes we see
a guy he's fits the criteria
and there are red flags but we ignore
them because we like him yeah
you know we've we're Hook Line and
Center for how gorgeous he is and we're
ignoring the fact that maybe we're just
not compatible maybe sometimes maybe
he's a good he's a good for a season but
it's not actually the father of the
child so a lot of times when you meet
women they'll say that you know um
obviously I've been cheated on or I have
trust issues I have trauma what have you
not and this comes from order I am so
tired it's come from all the all the
guys they picked right and before what
used to happen is like you said you got
brother you got all the brothers yeah so
yo I would have an interest in you
um I would come around to your house or
whatever your older brother would check
me over your dad your uncle have you not
they'll give me a list they still do
okay cool they will give me limited
access to you this is courting this is
not dating dating there's a 20th century
phenomenon there will be no there will
be no sexual activity going on the most
I could get was a was a peck on the
cheek once I do that and they check me
over this involves checking over my
family checking out who I was right cool
then they would say to me right I didn't
I didn't need to have money I need to
have good promise about me and I had to
be a good man that was the most
important thing then me and you were
going to go together and was going to go
and build it on what's happened now is
that's gone so you women now can pick
and you don't pick what makes sense you
make you pick what makes your fanny flow
apart in the language but it's because
you pick what makes you excited right
you see that feeling that tingling that
you get that's that usually comes from
bad boys well no and that actually comes
women in their 20s the number one thing
they select for is looks
so and women only find yeah maybe five
to twenty percent of men is attractive
good looking okay so so we're picking
for the wrong things but go ahead yeah
so question do you think that by having
that approach the more traditional
quoting kind of approach do you think
that that would solve all these problems
that were happening I think it would but
not but not for the women that are I
think like honestly if I was a guy in
2023 I'd say 25 plus done I wouldn't
even touch them because most of most
women yeah sorry and this is the
question yeah yeah we're all going for
lunch well no no well yes yes yes but
I'm saying like if I was a guy to really
you just got to go younger because most
of the most of the chicks are two
programs so so what was that yeah yeah
what's wrong with that a guy dating a
younger children how much younger are we
talking
um I mean adults
we're not talking about teenagers yeah
I'd say under 25 over 18. and I'll tell
you I'll tell you why because typically
over the age of 25 there's exceptions
right but we're just too programmed that
we're just like done yeah
so so my opinion I would like to ask a
question do you think a man is ready to
be married at 22 25 no no no she doesn't
matter no she marries up he marries down
yeah but it's just a question well so
and are women absolutely I would say I
would say most men at that age wanted to
get married young they usually get their
heart broke yeah like usually the men
want to get married young the women
don't and then they have such a tough
time with women most of us they just
become most of us start off right yeah
most of us start off like this you know
in school you know you know sending
little love hearts you know those little
cards you sent over there
will you be my Valentine's yes no maybe
take a box yeah we used to do this
because we were always by mothers that
told us son this is what you do here
this is how you treat the girl you go
get the chocolates then one day you just
see that that could come in the fresh
kickers and the Blazer and they go and
he gets all he's got the kickers he's
got the platform you know all the
different colors you know the different
color you know
yeah
and yeah he ain't doing nothing and
other than just being fresh here so so
then you go home and say mommy my mom
said don't worry son don't worry son
your time will come and the reason I'm
trying to say is it's completely
different you know
I'll tell you what I'll tell you what
tends to happen though it's similar
where the guys like they want the more
traditional thing when they're younger
they go for it and the women don't want
it I mean because think about it if if
we're not getting married until 31
that's the choice of the woman because
what man doesn't want a hot young chick
men from the ages of 20 to 80 think that
we're hottest at 22 and honestly some
some Studies have said 18. so some
Studies have said even younger than that
and so it's like okay they want the hot
young chicks they're not they're not
signing up to be wives I know some women
that are begging to get married no but
the problem is but I'll tell you I'll
tell you what happens to those guys
because typically
um one women aren't adding as much value
as they used to so they used to have
traditional like men are just like
they'll look at the cost and they'll
look at the benefits yeah right and the
problem is the cost is super high now
where a man you know I've interviewed
men all the time on the brink of suicide
because of divorce so you know where a
woman can ruin a man's reputation by
calling him an abuser with no evidence
right I mean we see we yeah a woman can
take a half of a man's a woman can
take the house put him on child support
put him on Alamo like I know men I
wouldn't be surprised if in the next two
three years they commended suicide
because these women have ruined their
life this is the cost okay and the women
have to come in and say Here's the
benefit I'm giving you okay
um unlimited sex for a lifetime well one
out of four marriages is a sexless so
that's not a thing okay I'm gonna be hot
forever I'm gonna be skinny no no we're
getting fat right right so then we come
in and say hey I won't give you seven
kids she says I'm not doing that and so
it's like we we have to ask like what
value at are women in 2023 so one way
that guys mitigate risk is they say Okay
I want to do the traditional thing I
want this but I don't want to end up
like that Uncle that Dad that person I
know so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
date the chick for years okay and just a
veteran let's make sure she's not crazy
easy because I've had a couple friends
they've said the girls get kind of crazy
after the kids and the marriage and I
don't want that to happen to me so
that's what they'll do but really I I
think it's like they need they need to
change the divorce laws and that's why I
say women have to give up power because
I don't think we'll see the family
structure and traditionalism ever come
back until women say okay we're not
going to go to the workforce or at least
we can't get divorced anymore no fault
divorce is gone because right now the
risk is too high because a woman can
just say I'm not feeling it and ruin his
life
I think if you have a baby not really so
so uh child support they only get it
they only men only get custody of their
kids 10 of the time
men get the worst deal yeah that's true
actually obviously see seen as more
nurture and so sometimes it's just
assuming and there's no evidence that
women raise better children yeah it's
actually that men raise better children
I personally think a child should have
both a mother and a father figure and
that I mean well and on average takes it
takes three years for a girl to get a
ring so if you want to if you want to be
married on average it'll take you three
years
[Laughter]
fathers I know and this is out of choice
they have good relationships with the
mothers of their kids willingly have
their children every other weekend so by
choice
so okay how do you how do you know that
because I've been with them no no so I'm
asking so the guys say that yeah well so
and I'll tell you one thing a lot of
guys are actually embarrassed and and
they don't want to tell you about it
it's it's very common well because I
mean it's pretty demasculating to have
the woman that you had a child with take
you to the cleaner in court that's not
something men typically want to talk
about
um it's usually pretty embarrassing to
them obviously because they're not in
power like in that situation they can't
really take control obviously well I
just think I think if you stop
women should spend like a week or two in
Family Court just to see what happens
I'll give you an example so I
interviewed a guy he had text evidence
um she planned to divorce him and this
was a woman that was a Christian woman
she was like from Eastern Europe like
she was all the green flags like no no
only fans know nothing right and I don't
say this to be a Doomer and gloomer but
it like this this is not uncommon okay
and she had texts she basically she got
a feminist friend around her and women
were just really easily influenced like
that's why we get the latest fashion
trends that's why we just go with the
group we kind of have group think I
don't know why she gets a feminist
friend right the feminist friend starts
like telling her all this feminist
jargon the feminist friend is telling
her can you get him to hit you yeah so
and this is I and I saw the text I I
literally he he showed me his court
documents of her trying to get him to
hit her so she could go to court and
call him an abuser because the way it
works in England is you actually there
are government incentives
um to to give you it's either a free
lawyer or some side some kind of legal
aid if you are an abuse victim and when
they implemented that policy abuse
charges went up 400 percent so so that
like you know and so imagine like this
is the girl that's been on your arm for
five years this is the mother like men
are a little bit more like tactful when
the mother of their children like the
mother of their child is an absolute
wench they don't go on social media and
talk about it they don't complain to the
whole time like men really suffer inside
because there's a huge L like last last
year I was talking about my friends that
are going through the matters Court
about all the amount of money that had
to go have to spend and it's just that
thing where it's like
part of my job in the magnum's voice is
I'd be speaking to so much men this last
year Pearl all the time right and I've
discovered like I would find out yeah I
was very poor marriage and I still
believe in in marriage and what have you
know in different circumstances whatever
I actually believe you should probably
have a baby woman first to see if she's
gonna be crazy
um but because you know because they
always say women changes
honestly honestly as someone I believe
in marriage I'm a Catholic I think
that's the best way to do it I agree you
don't understand how I started on this
podcast I was like I have three sisters
four years I'm the only one that's not
married now I'm out here like I'm like I
want to get married but but it's like
women have so much power when they have
the children don't they because often
men could be left
never seen their child or if they do see
the child it comes with conditions and
we don't talk about that enough and and
I interviewed a guy a guy like because a
lot of times they'll say like that I
always see the church Community just say
get married young that's the solution
and and it's hard because like as a
Catholic I'm like I think that that's
better for most people or it would have
been if we didn't have a system that's
paying women to be terrible uh like I'll
give you an example this guy he dated he
married a woman and she was so into him
she switched religions for him so she
went from I don't know she's Christian
or Catholic or something she became a
muslim
okay okay okay but I'm saying so like
this was a girl that like you know he he
thinks he's gonna be a good mother
whatever and she ends up um now he
hasn't seen the kid in two and a half
years wow and the kid hates him so you
know they'll say well what about your
legacy how do you have a legacy when the
mother is talking so much and it's
funny because like the girl that was
here before it was probably her mom
talking about her dad because
usually when they I don't even say this
to like be me I've just seen the same
family Dynamics yeah
they're a single mother or a lot of
times I found this just I don't know I
found this from more traditional
cultures where when they come in and
they're saying oh like it was so awful
and evil a lot of a lot of the times
it's because
um the mom was saying how awful and evil
it was for her and scaring the daughter
I don't this is just it's the same thing
so well I I don't know we don't know her
circumstances to be fair and sometimes
it's the environment it could be peers
but yes we hear things in the household
and we repeat like for instance as you
said Pearl you know if a mother she has
so much power over her children
and regardless of whether the
relationship is really really bad it's
so wrong when we as women say bad things
about the father to the child and I
think that's one of the things we should
never ever ever do and that's the
problem that's where it starts and We
complain about men but actually we are
the keepers of men because we have boys
we are mothers and so if we grew our
boys in a certain way what a difference
it would be fact so what do you think
about the other way around should a man
speak bad in his how many times do you
see that no way no way it barely happens
to be fair I've seen it happen okay
if they if they do she's usually no yeah
in this situation no why is Grace given
to the man though in in this instance I
guess I'll tell you why I'll tell you
why it's because you just start to see
trends like it's just a weird thing that
happens when you start to interview like
hundreds of hundreds of people it's like
I can talk to someone and kind of guess
their backstory with I'm not saying I'm
always right but you know you just start
to see like patterns of behavior
um and women just tend to complain more
we're just kind of big whiners go to any
protests it's mostly women like now
women love a protest
argument no but you know what I I hope
we're taking from this right it's like
end of the days men and women need to
have better conversations and we speak
different we're different right I'm
always going to speak direct I'm always
going to speak in a way they're probably
going to rub people up the way that's
because that's gonna get us the way we
need to get to but at the end of the day
I'm not your enemy like like I want the
best for like I love women that don't
even know me you know I because I'll
protect you and the moment I will do
that is because it's just one of those
things not all men have it not all men
have it but most men do have it but if a
man doesn't have it you shouldn't he
might not be raised that but like that
to be uh to not every single you can't
build a bear you can't a lot of women
want emotional men they're gonna speak
to them they listen to their day and at
the same time when a guy says something
and they want him to go and knock him
out it's not it doesn't work
no you can't just Build A Bear you
either you either get guys like me or
you go no I'm saying you might you might
be able to get both in it but what do
you mean a guy like me this is not
aggression trust me I'm not I'm you're
no way in a danger of me the only thing
is is what I'm going to say but we
cannot be keep tone police and Men
because what happens is we have to
shrink ourselves in order to speak to
you let me be and that's wrong and I'll
let you be you and then together we can
you know and that's the other thing like
we all know how serious an abuse
allegation is for a guy so when we're
going around saying oh you're being
aggressive you're being aggressive yeah
it's actually like it's triggering I'll
be honest when she said about the black
thing that hurt me
like the natural hair is like but again
if it touches on the nerve you're going
to speak for next I understand that but
to say she also had natural hair so she
just speaking on the behalf of those who
wear she probably has natural hair
because she hasn't fixed that week yeah
okay guys guys I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna Read Super I'm gonna Read Super
chats for a second okay
um she'd be like let me see your hair
okay all right 46 and two says Joe Biden
is the president of the divided States
of America thanks in large part to
single mothers and women um Bonnie chan
oh my gosh yeah no that's so true that's
so true that's what guys I'll tell you
I'll tell you what was the the nail in
the coffin for Pearl when I said because
I you know the first time I said women
shouldn't vote I swear I swear it was a
joke I was kidding I was like God we're
so emotional maybe we should just like
return our room and I was no I was it
was a joke at first right then
um and then I just started to think
about it I started my divorce
documentary so guys if you don't know
I'm doing a documentary on divorce where
I wanted to figure out why it was so
hard for men to get their children I was
like this is wrong and and it's
especially like tugs at my heartstrings
because kids are innocent right kids are
the most innocent people like they just
like they deserve to have a father and
especially especially being like where
where I'm from I'm really close with my
dad and I just know the impact that my
dad had on me and I'm like every kid
deserves to grow up with a father and so
I started you know researching and
looking more and more and more and I
started to ask like the men's rights
activists which are men are men and
women that have been fighting for men to
have equal rights in court and in the
legal system for years but have had made
little to no progress and they told me
they said
we will it is very difficult to pass
anything because all the politicians
cannot get elected unless they cater to
women so passing these policies would be
a death sentence to their career and I
just went to think about it and I just
thought how is that fair when men do all
of the work
I I don't think it's fair and I think
now the kids are the one who suffers
which really brings me these women on my
couches that I have to kick out because
most of them were raised by single
mothers so I really was looking out for
myself I was like maybe the couches
could be a little more a little more you
know I like see I like this Vibe you
know it's a little better
um okay Dr David Baker according to the
American Journal of Public Health 49.7
of domestic violence is reciprocal
and 70 listen to this 70 of
non-reciprocal violence was inflicted by
the woman
meanwhile when men are twice as likely
to be a victim of Street violence so
actually when we look at domestic
violence that's one-sided the women are
are more likely to do it than the men
most of the time they're beating the
out of each other that's what Aaron
pizzi will tell you and she started the
first Domestic Abuse Center and worked
in domestic abuse for like 20 30 years
okay Dragon stallion one zero zero one
woman on the couch if if if a woman is
hating a guy and the man defends himself
who should the police remove from the
house for domestic violence woman
[Music]
90 Frito pie a strong man is only a week
or a strong woman is only a weak man
women want the same rules in their
living room to apply to the whole world
women live women live in the movie they
Direct in their heads all right beaten
cheeks
um
he seems like he's got a lot going on I
don't all right after everything goes
down in the west do you guys believe we
are now living in a matriarchal society
yes yes I do believe we're living in a
matriarchal society because it's like
who has the most power right now women
are the ones voting women are the ones
spending we make 80 percent of consumer
buying decisions I actually would go in
as far to say like men are robbed like
basically men pay all the taxes for the
society to run and women don't really
give them anything in return most of
them don't realize it but and they're
yeah women and we have all the power in
hiring we have all these quotas for
women all these special the entire
school system is run by women yeah yes
um although I will say men can all get
together and take power back they can do
that so well think about it if all the
the only reason we have rights in the
first place is because men gave them to
us yeah yeah and then we'll we'll call
them abusers I'm like you realize we're
allowed to do anything right now
like if men were these abusive men we'd
all just be in like sex cages or
something
I
said yep that's what we're gonna do no
men are pretty nice um okay example new
wave of feminism giving entitled women
jobs they don't deserve accusing
innocent men for hurt feelings
um the ginger Menace for your Kick Out
camera I can't wait to get one I hope
you get it and are able to use it soon
I'll always donate to a great cause
Patrick Mills she said she'd protect a
man being threatened but she's been
taught that men won't hit a woman in
front of people so grow up feeling
bullet bulletproof in protection beaten
cheeks again I'm to the only man to the
only thing to the only fans model with
the high IQ what value do you bring to a
man of value that wants to build a
family because bringing a child that
isn't in his relationship do you think
he'll be respected by his peers
Matt San black female in the corner and
the women on the couch are why nobody
respects women anymore a nation can rise
no higher than its women it's women it's
women who have doomed us Dr David Baker
the the tone policing on this panel is
off the chain ladies when you say it's
not what you say it's how you say it
you're just screaming from the rooftops
I have no actual argument I'm just angry
because you're right the Savvy ninja I'm
gonna use that yes yes I'm gonna use
that the Savvy ninja bro calm down
you're coming across you're coming
across aggressive I'm not simply a black
man either masculine doesn't mean louder
stoicin is a must must as a man slow
down stop screaming
um percless you're done it's not a
trauma response it's a woman attempting
to shut down criticism they know it's
true of themselves women aren't ignorant
to their poor choices standard banter
the more I watch these shows the more I
want to join the passport Bros
uh beaten cheeks hey
yeah hey Pearl I love hey Pearl I love
that you are using my sympademic
movement I started Andrew Wilson likes
the sympocalypse but I have a sympedemic
trademark to use with my names with my
name attached to destroy the Sims yes
this is my actually I actually think I I
think Sims irritate me more than women
I'll tell you modern women the crazy
chicks
um because sips like have it in them
like women I just don't even think we
have it in us to be fully rational we're
too emotional but the sips have it in
them
that's what I mean
I mean they kind of know they kind of
who knows we like I think Freud said we
had child Minds it's like all right but
but the guys like and then once you
start
pandering you can unsee it so the guys
will come on and they'll say yes I love
women with high body counts yes I love
these fat women and I'm like
and I'm like and the worst part is I'll
see their girlfriends they're never
either of those things and I'm like stop
Simpson tell us like stop it and then
they make me do this podcast because
they're they're just too Wim like it's
like not now but this is fun so it's all
right okay beating cheeks oh my God
he is beating them he actually he
actually just did the same Super Chat
twice so yeah yeah yeah he loves that
he's really excited about the sympademic
it is it's an epidemic it's like okay
I'll tell you guys another thing that
happened to me this week I um basically
all these simps came in there was a guy
named Crowder he was a conservative
commentator and he had his wife lika a
camera footage accusing him of abuse he
didn't touch her he was like yelling
and she was pregnant correct and he told
it to work and I got the full like
because she is like she and she and what
she did was she edited it
he didn't look like he was moving a bit
mad in it though no no so what happened
was she she basically said he said um
I'll you up and she fled the house
but when I listened to the audio he he
he was getting mad because basically
this man was being gasoline in his own
house she kept accusing him of abuse and
he said stop stop just because he said
I'll you up this time and so he
said I'll you up and he said wait
I'm sorry I didn't mean it okay so right
so right at like doesn't abuse yourself
does it correct doesn't abuser say I'm
sorry I didn't mean it like that's not
really he that's a guy who lost his
temper for a second no no they don't
they say that's why I didn't mean again
but he didn't know but he he and then
she admitted I had affidavits where she
admitted she's never been hit by him
never been abused by him and then all
these stamps these deals all of these
simps went around they destroyed this
man's character so they went around on
all the media platforms calling him an
abuser even though there's no police
report no actual real evidence and then
I I out of the kindness of my heart I I
showed the real footage I gave them the
real story and I thought they'd come
forward and be super happy with me and
Report the truth and none of them did
none of them apologized none of them
retracted and it was so disappointing
because I'm like uh how are we gonna
move forward if we can't even and they
all took the woman's side and we're like
well it's emotional abuse oh it's this
is that I'm like do you know it's
emotional abuse
putting a clip out calling him an abuser
what about Russell Brand now I was just
gonna say that I was just gonna yeah
yeah and
and all the men and this is the thing
the men I'm like the men no like that
men know who's an abused like they just
can vet each other muscle brand ah
listen listen I I don't believe I don't
I don't believe in it I'll be honest
with you Russell Brad has always been
open about who he is he's always been
open about his about his past and about
Hollywood and the things he's done the
things he's seen
um in the last few years has completely
changed what he's been doing obviously
he's been on the Hawkins conspiracy
angle you want to say so I just think
they're trying to come from and come and
for him to be to be demonetized by
YouTube it's basically suicide it's
basically this sentence right yeah and
then they tried to come for rumble and
Rumble wasn't having it and it's like
this thing where where this cancer
culture where something happens right
and all of a sudden now you're guilty
and you and you're trial by social media
and I don't lucky because the same thing
that happened to Benjamin Mendy
obviously he was found obviously he was
found not guilty same thing happened to
no Clark and he's had his whole career
ruined right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
what do you guys think I think that
women should not be allowed to press
charges I think you get a year to press
them and I think after a year you
shouldn't be allowed well I agree with
it I agree with that to a point but what
I think is is that we need to go to
court and prove
whether someone is guilty or not
I don't think that you should I don't
think they should lose their career I
don't think anything should be canceled
what do we do
so many people who could be innocent and
then you've destroyed their life in
their life but what do we do after
you've been dragged through social
because you know once you've been
accused of something it's over for you
right you're not gonna yeah and
especially with the way the fact that
Brands can just drop you because they
just don't want because they're trying
to please they're trying to please women
they're trying to please that so that's
the thing what do we do with the women
that bring men to the and then like they
just go back into it I'd like to ask the
question why why is it that so many
women
it would seem
that they don't have a problem with the
fact that a man's life has been
destroyed before they know if he's
guilty
I won't just think to myself oh say to
them no no but I'd really like to
understand I think they assume obviously
they deep down believe but is it because
they've been hurt is it because they're
traumatized because someone did
something I'll tell you what I see
there's like two types
and one of them is like basically the
feminists come in and expand the
definition of abuse and they expand that
they change the definition of things and
you kind of see women do this in normal
language like when they say uh cheating
is abuse no that's the new one no when
they say misogyny misogyny for
everything yeah yeah if you call a woman
if you call a woman out of what she's
doing then you're misogynistic yeah yeah
so they start to change like the
definition of words so what women did is
rape used to be
forced carnal which is basically forced
sex and that's pretty that's pretty easy
to identify someone pulls you off the
side of the road they switch the
definition to sex without consent and
the the that word flip consent is
subjective
okay I'll give you I'll give you an
example about coercion okay so that's
another feminist word that doesn't
really mean anything screaming grooming
another feminist word agreement I I'm
not saying there aren't examples but the
way they typically use it I mean I see
them using it with 22 year olds how the
are they yeah I feel like I
disagree with that yeah some people
always go to extremes though they're
always someone that well and they kind
of uh you know and even even now they're
they're trying to say the 16 year old
you know you might not like it but
that's legal
right that's legal and you know I and I
when I was 16 honestly I knew you know
what you're doing like I don't know this
idea like if a guy commits a crime at
16.
you know I mean
like he goes to jail usually why do
women get absolved of anything when
they're 16.
um actually young men so in general just
youth 16 17 year olds um they tend not
to get put in jail for certain crimes
because obviously
mm-hmm because they're still young yeah
but they still go to juvie though they
still get locked up I know I know quite
a few people that they've for example
they've got youth caution instead of
anything so obviously once you're 18
yeah that gets wiped off your record so
purely because
um yeah they want to believe in second
chances obviously because they're young
they don't know what they're doing they
shouldn't even as a kid well and and the
other and the other uh yeah but I'm
saying you're not absolved but okay I'll
tell you I'll tell you I'll tell you
what happened with abuse though so what
happened with abuse is they expanded the
definition to be emotional abuse
Financial abuse these words that really
only benefit the women and never talk
about like when the women emotionally
abuse them and it all becomes subjective
right and so the feminists will come in
at the women's shelters and the lawyers
and they'll come to the whim and often
in the institution they literally teach
this in schools where they'll say oh if
you're drunk you didn't consent what the
or and you're drunk you you still robbed
the store you go to jail why the hell
are you absolved from accountability
because you decided to get drunk and
that's the key word you know
accountability correct I think
why is it as a woman okay never never
should somebody assault you or do
something Force you I'm not I'm not
advocating it but but hearing lies this
is then at no point that you might say
to yourself well
if I hadn't of done this then that
wouldn't have happened it might work for
example
like I guess I don't want to a very
famous person and you go to that
person's house at two o'clock in the
morning
and this person is interested in every
woman here but you happen to be the one
that goes
why would you say something happened
because maybe you didn't end up in a
relationship with that person because
you wanted more from it do you
understand my point
it didn't happen the way you wanted it
yeah
and there is something wrong with that
now I'm not saying that what anybody
does is right I'm just saying that I as
an individual look at myself and say
well
I'll make sure I don't do that again
that's what I mean my consequently I'll
take my own personal responsibility so
when I speak to men like and I said this
last time I say to men don't you know
I'm at work don't don't speak to any
women at work you know that's not like
that used to be someone where you would
meet your wife but now it's somewhere
where you'll catch a case and end up in
HR and I know and we laugh about it but
it's fine but it's true since the metoo
movement I would never recommend any man
to be speaking to any one of his
colleagues because it comes out it comes
at a huge risk if she likes your
advances it's going to be all fun and
games if she doesn't she's going to be
at Karen and HR in the morning and
you're losing your job are they telling
you about workplace misconduct and
inappropriate behavior and stuff like
that because it's been changed so far
and men have to protect themselves and
and you know I think that isn't that
hypocrisy why is it that if a woman
fancies you your advances are okay yeah
but if she doesn't answer you it's
because it deemed as something that is
negative it's because it's because does
that mean that we've forgotten how to
have discernment yes because because
because what's happened now is like what
Pearl said is like someone is going to
say to you that was wrong you shouldn't
have done that and then they're gonna
start just tapping you on the shoulder
before you know you've got two people
that said actually what happened to you
wasn't what you thought it was or
something else and then now HR is going
to lead the case that's that's what
happens it's usually the feminists will
say oh no that's abuse you were abused
that was rape that was sexual assault so
they'll they'll they'll come in and yeah
and we just and then and then there's
also malicious like actually evil women
that know this and that will just abuse
and also of course women that I for
example don't get um I said or yeah
right like um they would say that they
got great for example that also
yeah
um so a woman that actually did get
abused for example they can't really
speak up now because obviously that
makes that more invalid so obviously if
you say something like if you're gonna
make a point
like you know what I mean I'll be honest
with you I didn't realize I've been in
quite a few abusive relationships until
I started doing podcasts and I didn't
actually understand
click on it no because I speak a lot now
because I speak a lot but I've been on
the journey and it's only by having
conversations and the more and more I've
been like well I've actually been in
abusive relationships like I've actually
um
like nothing nothing like not not like
physical but but some emotional
psychological manipulation like and
verbal oh oh verb hello today I wasn't
even in a relationship and I was hella
verbal and
no like she's gonna keep getting it
that's what she's gonna keep cooking
because end of the day is is I want
people to understand what us men go
through people call me emotional I'm not
emotional and passionate that's all it
is like I'm definitely not an emotional
person because if I was I already
reacted emotional I was trying to have
conversations but I speak to women that
react emotional when you start insulting
people start to send shots that's when
it's because I've hit you somewhere and
that's not what but part of see you need
to take this medicine yeah you might not
like the taste of it but it's gonna fix
you she didn't want to take the medicine
because I've done this thing with only I
have so many only fans goals and
strippers on my friends we're cool we're
cool do you know why we're cool because
they understand where I come from they
know that I'm not like these other guys
I'm not sure an actual fact we can have
a we can have a um a friendship right
based upon the fact that I don't respect
what you do I don't like what you do but
I understand you've got to do what you
do as long as you're trying to get out
of it at some point yeah it's cool and
why does like why does the way because
what a lot of times women every they'll
use their feelings to justify doing
anything and they always feel like they
did it first when usually it's like you
know what it is it's like and it's like
what what is like what does your
feelings have to dictate how you act you
know what I mean like you don't have to
be like emotionally let like you know I
I just think there's a baseline level of
respect and even if someone doesn't give
it to you immediately it's like you
could still be calm it doesn't have to
change the way that you act you just
reminding me of a person to make so like
we're talking about aggression and male
aggression is expressed completely
different from female aggression now
males tend to express their aggression
physically most of the time because we
have the tools to do that yeah women on
the other hand tend to express their
aggression for the most part verbally
psychologically yeah emotionally and
here's the thing as men
no matter how emotional we feel we have
to control our aggression because it can
bring devastating power to the world as
women
you think oh yeah just because it's not
physical I can let it all out but you
don't understand
me bro
no she was violating me and the thing is
this uncoupled on the fact that as men
if I put if I bring my aggression out to
you you can you can bring yourself but
I'm not going to do it but as a woman if
she brings aggression out to me I'm just
gonna have to take it do you remember
and then if you bring yours to her
yes exactly and that's what and that's
for sure do it what are you gonna do no
I understand I know and that's what the
women will do is like they'll be like oh
he did this this and this like I
actually find that women that claim
abuse are abusive because what like how
did like I just want to know what
happened like he came home you're being
a perfect angel and then he got mad some
of the time now there's nothing
okay these days more more than not
that's just what I see because when you
ask them questions about it like this is
what they'll come on the show they'll
say I was abused I was this I was that
whatever and I'll say okay what happened
like I'll give you an example one girl
comes on she says I was abused and she
said he pushed me I think it's like he
pushed me down the stairs or something
bad right she pushed me out of the house
oh yeah yeah and it turns out she
wouldn't leave his house
so apparently he asked her to leave
during an argument and he asked her to
leave his house and she said she's not
gonna leave and then it was back and
forth and then he pushed her out the
house and now he's on abused like have
we have we had one girl give us a real
story no but that doesn't sound like a
woman though doesn't it and that's and
and like like just usually usually
there's more to the story usually like a
lot of times and then okay I'll give you
another example right there's a guy that
there was a clip of him he goes viral he
freaks out and he hits a chick now why
did he do that because she spoke ill of
his dead son
she was taunting him about his dead son
who abused who and that's the
conversation women don't have is like
okay you know sometimes a man can only
take so much so you know you've
emotionally abused him for months and
one day the guy snaps and I'll tell you
this you're gonna start looking at a lot
of murder cases in the news where the
guys like freak out right and they'll
freak out kill their whole family not
saying obviously that's bad right but
you start to look at the reasons why and
a lot of times that woman has
emotionally tormented that guy for
months in divorce court and then one day
he freaks out and just goes crazy
yeah but I'm I'm explaining like it's
not reported that side correct but it's
like whenever a woman does something
wrong we'll always talk about the reason
but we never talk about the guy's reason
for doing things and he does something
wrong and like we talk about so even
Keisha with the girl that go bricks in
the face didn't get bricked in the face
right whatever happened and I knew I
knew I knew she was doing something
because I'm like well okay I didn't
think it was I knew when that girl with
the brick on her face I I knew um like I
didn't know if it was fake but I was
like what were you doing to get brick
so when I first saw it I posted it and
King sent me some stuff and he said to
me you might want to look into this a
little bit further because because I
kind of went with the with the thing oh
my God they broke the girl in the face
like are you nuts what was the context
like what actually happened she said she
faked it
though
she's lesbians yeah
that's feminism well and she would go
around hitting like white people just
because they're white okay that's messed
up yeah and she was something about
reparations
I'm like Irish
no the reason why I say it yeah is
because it's because
this thing where women go up to men that
they do not know and then they are
disrespectful and rude and aggressive so
she didn't think she was being
aggressive but like we say our
aggression is different from your
aggression so she was using venomous
tongue literally a venomous tongue and
words in which and she was doing that
right because she knew what she was
doing and that's aggression right but
that's the thing if you would hit her
after she taunted you about it then then
you would have been an abuser then I've
been an abuser but the problem the thing
is yeah is do that outside and the man
why did the man hit you if I do that to
a man I know that I don't know he can
hit me and I'm aware of that it doesn't
make it okay it's what regulates us men
right but you she proved how safe she
was because she was insulting a man that
twice look at the size of me yeah but
let's let's wind it back though let's
look at it this way if that's something
that happens frequently
are there many women who don't realize
you don't realize that they're being so
antagonistic but they feel safe
that there's no way this man can hit me
and I can say what I like yeah
there's I think that there are women who
don't actually realize that their
attitude and their language how
dangerous and how abusive it is I I
don't think it's fair I just don't think
that's removing accountability yeah it
is yeah it is it is but I don't think
they're realized no but they do because
uh because listen that she said educated
they don't they don't care to listen
she's a 23 year old girl she's in
University she's got all the mouth right
she's educated she's not stupid you're
not stupid she knows exactly what she's
done she knew who she was speaking to
she seen me on social media and she came
with an agenda she came with an agenda
and that was the whole thing she came to
show China I'm gonna show him right she
thought she had receipts and that's what
she wanted to come with I'm not blaming
you women right I don't know any of you
women from anywhere right you guys
Banner together because you're women and
that's what you're doing and I was the
one guy here I never made any I never
meant any disrespect or anything but I
will just show you what Usman have to
deal with so I'm looking at things right
if this is how the young women are going
out onto the roads and you're talking to
men listen man is going to slap you up
you know man is going to punch you up
and you and with
they always look at history they kind of
like we gotta start looking at history
different sometimes there's a reason we
did things they used to kill women they
used to kill I swear they used to kill
women that they thought were poisonous
to the group they'd be like nope which
he's casted spells that they would be
like women that would be performing
abortions they're like oh no they used
to think that women on their periods
were witches or something like that I
know that they used to think if there
was too emotional they'd perform his
hysterectomy oh yeah
yeah I'm taking all of you out but I'm
just like them well yeah and they'd call
like I really think like in 2023 like
we're just seeing female hysteria at a
mass like they used to talk about this
and I don't remember the ins and outs of
it but like uh like Parts in history
where females just had like hysteria I I
think we're going crazy because of
social media yeah I don't think we're
like meant to me just to blame for a lot
of things not social media people on the
platform because at the end of the days
like people that are actually using
those music the way that their music's
being used I actually gotta say you know
women
um I think we're kind of evil
let me explain
okay okay so I think that women aren't
always evil right but you know we got
the right to vote in the early 1900s
around 1920 they said women in power and
you know we got the choice to
what oh does he have a train or
something okay I'll finish this really
quick we we got a choice to do anything
right and what happened when the
politicians started catering to us we
made policies that abused men that took
away their children uh weren't a ton of
debt and yeah I think women are meant to
submit to the authority of men and when
we don't do that that's when evil
happens no man there's a lot of evil
happening before
and I'll tell you I'll tell you you're
actually right you're actually right
there is evil happening but typically
what happens with men is they're good
people so Men If a woman
man I'll tell I'll tell you why
let me let me let me explain I'll tell
you why so when the men when one man is
acting out of pocket what did we see in
the clip
the other men came to stop them they
they're good people right did you see
any women trying to stop them yeah now
now I'll give you an example what do
women do when they're left to their own
devices we become
you can speak for yourself
[Music]
but that's how the modern woman thinks
tell you I'll tell you see it now did
you see that did you see that she got
triggered so she attacks me and I'll
tell you what I'll tell you wait it was
you wait wait wait wait listen listen
okay I'll tell you why because I don't
care are you a virgin okay so a hundred
years ago yeah basically yeah I'll
tell you why me too
it's all right we're in 2023 and what's
20 23 women left to our own devices okay
again 85 percent of women were virgins
100 years ago wait wait wait wait okay
wait thank you four percent of us are on
only fans so I mean when left to our own
devices we could do anything I see I see
wives and mothers with ass pictures on
Instagram wow this is women given
Freedom so you know for whatever reason
we just make awful decisions that are
pretty evil so do you think not being
about as being a then
um so I had to think about this I'll
tell you why I had to think about this
and I came up with some definitions so
you know I'd say there's a
historical now we're in 2023 baby
you know what I mean so it's like now if
you went to a guy today and I said I
know this chick she's only been with two
guys the guys would be like Hallelujah
so so so I'm like all right we can't use
that definition because it wouldn't work
but I'm like a hundred years ago the men
would be like you're marrying a
non-virgin they would be like oh no get
get one of the get one of the younger no
don't do that so I was like in all of
history two bodies is a now in
2023 really I guess no you know God uh
the men basically are saying like over
seven you're a maybe to ten that's
like what the guys have kind of said
yeah seven to ten years yeah that's kind
of where you like you go from woman I I
actually have a chart of whoredom you
guys can check out yeah I do I do I go
through these definitions you know I go
I go I break down every single one but
yeah so
um yeah if you go into history yeah I'd
say
but oh so yeah but back to women are
evil
um yeah so so women are evil because you
know when we are left to our own devices
and given all of the choice we seem to
be and oppressed men well at
least you said we that's all right and
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah anyways
um go final thoughts I know we're in a
hurry so go ahead final thoughts
um um yeah yeah like I don't even I
don't even know if I don't even know
what I was trying to do this show but
they kind of run it off but yeah it was
like it was cool show like it was nice
to end well I really I really appreciate
you know you're being so aggressive
well let's say that again China no I
just really appreciate your take and you
being here you was very balanced like I
just we needed that yeah like I I
respect my orders I I respect women so I
take you know I mean and the rest of the
lady on the couch I don't really think
yeah like I just yeah you know what I
mean um yeah my name is voice go
subscribe to my channel my name is China
my name's Uncle YouTube go subscribe
subscribe run it up shout out to Pearl
um you know big up
King the producer shout out to NCC
security because they got me covered
because he's got to be crazy out
out get out
all right all right thank you for that
go ahead okay yeah final conclusion yeah
just let's treat everyone with respect
man keep love at the foremost treat each
other properly yeah so so good so gravy
I'm G money you can find me on anything
other than only phones
okay sorry I ain't got that now
well I feel like the the bait was
obviously much better when it was Karma
more respect and I think that's how
every conversation should go 100 bring
your fellow women left this
I feel like it comes down to an
individual and them two are not
you can't really have a proper
conversation with someone that speaks
with emotion and not logic
[Music]
yep
I feel like it's good that we were able
to have a very nuanced and balanced view
towards the end of the session
sorry big big vocab
um I am JoJo you can find me at Joe
Excel Artistry on Instagram at joe.xo
artist
and a pleasure guys it's been here
I've learned a lot as well you know yeah
yeah so yeah I feel like I changed my
views on a few things to be honest are
you a feminist though me yeah yes
you're you're 18. I'm 18 yeah she she
can be fixed now
there's nothing to fix yeah guys all you
gotta do we just gotta find like a
conservative guy to date her she'll be
like yeah
I'm gonna stay away from them well women
women we just like adapt to whoever's
around us so if you get if you get a
girl a girl's like feminist will dated
conservative Guy They'll be like I'm in
shirts like a month later
vice versa
vice versa all right yeah
I always I can't remember who did you
already do yourself
okay hi yeah um I'm Angie the voice
montut that's you can find me on all the
socials but what I really got from this
today
um and thank you to Pope my first time
on your show
um I just think that I'm not really for
the them and US argument I think the
more we can come together the more we
can understand each other fundamentally
respect each other
but there needs to be more self-respect
and accountability right and I think we
saw that here today right yeah yeah for
example exactly and if we do that and we
listen and please please please listen
to the men they do have something to say
that is valuable
just because they're passionate doesn't
mean that they're being aggressive
and it's a minority of men that might be
not so great I think most of them are
loving and if we as women remember to be
loving and we come together I think that
would change a lot
yeah um I think it was a very great
conversation
um generally I just think that
that
a lot of people just feel like because
it's a new ideology then it's right and
and that's a problem just because
something is new doesn't make it right
and just because something is old
doesn't make you wrong and I think that
as people generally we are always
searching for like trendy things to to
like jump on and it's not getting better
with the way we see things in the modern
you know Society so um I just think that
we need to have a very you know in if
not a very a very um you know Corporate
Way that we see things because when when
everyone is just going with oh you know
it's my life you know it's my child but
your child is going to meet my child out
there though right
that's a problem so we need to have that
very Collective mindset of you know how
we see ourselves as a people yeah oh my
name is Solomon buchito on on all
platforms
someone had a funny comment Pearl is
right I think it's about respect Amber
Rose is a proud 304 who started his
walk share almost 80 took her man a
senior citizen still Amber's boyfriend
yeah yeah yeah because Amber was like
he's so awful and then Cher is like no
he's a lovely man
um okay
um all right guys I think oh you got
some takers in the chat they're like
I'll figure Phil said they'll fix you
I'm good I'm good I'm good thanks
um okay let me just make sure there's no
super chats guys okay we're doing our
meet up Sunday you guys are all invited
if you want to come it's on my Instagram
the info which is just pearly things one
but is that is that either Flatiron
square or Grace is it the steak place no
no it's either square or grill I know
there's two squares
London Bridge yeah yeah that's it so the
show guests are all they'll are they're
all gonna be there they just canceled
their plans for the weekend
I wanted to work yeah yeah all you got
to do is show up no weird we are
having a security right here we wouldn't
mess with the security guard right guys
you don't trust me
um they said all right couple super
chats facts over feelings ladies holiday
tone W analogy for the brother on the
couch they've learned something from the
analogy
um thank you guys for watching can we
get to 2 000 likes before the end of the
video um that's the most important thing
that pushes out these streams thanks for
watching I'll talk to you next time